Ja, ja, das ist ein witziger
Standard, Standard.
Das ist der CLI-Ad-Kram, oder?
Was ist ein Standard, Standard-Issue?
Ich dachte, ja, das haben wir seit
vier
Folgen immer weiter in diesem Pad
geschoben. MWM-Install-Funding.
Das ist mittlerweile schon wieder abgegessen
und geklärt, das Ding. Achso, das ist echt alt.
Die haben schon komplett revertet.
Dann nehmen wir das raus. Und den No-CLI-Ads
Dings auch gleich, oder?
Ruby Gems Fuck der Woche?
Fuck ab der Woche?
gab der vor drei Wochen.
Dann waren Datenspuren.
Stimmt, das waren Datenspuren.
Das waren seitdem auch noch.
Wollen wir uns mal schnell ein paar aktuelle Themen
ausdenken? Ausdenken? Ja, ich schaue
auch mal auf Hacker News.
Das sind eindeutig Google-Farben hier, oder?
Eindeutig Google-Farben. Das sind rot,
blau, grün, gelb. Ja, aber das sind so diese schönen
matten Material Colors.
Mathematical. Würde ich zumindest behaupten.
Ich meine, vielleicht ist das auch grober Bullshit.
Das ist die Gopher
Dance Group. Ich hatte heute mal wieder
die Freude, in Go
reinschauen zu dürfen.
Ist es nicht eine tolle Sprache?
Warum zum Geier sind da Pointer
drin? Warum zum Geier kriegen die
Nullable Types hin? Weil sie Pointer
haben. Weil das ist so eine dumme
moderne Sprache. Das ist keine moderne
Sprache. Ja, doch. Vom Datum
her halt schon. Es ist eine neue Sprache.
Aber
Kobol war trotzdem bereits besser.
Es gibt einen richtig geilen Vortrag.
Das sieht aber schon eine gewagte Ausdruck.
War es Allgäu oder Kobol?
Es gibt einen richtig geilen Talk
über
Functional Programming und Imperative
Programming von Kevin Henley.
Kevin Henley?
Kevin Henny?
Der hatte ein L
an einer komischen Stelle.
Kevin
und der hat
darüber geredet,
Imperative ist quasi fast functional,
weil
was du unter Imperative verstehst, ist nicht,
was Imperative ursprünglich mal gemeint hat
und auch übrigens hier ist ein Beispiel in
ich bin mir nicht sicher, Kobol oder Algol
und danach kam C und C war eigentlich
schon eine Verschlechterung.
Aber egal, ich glaube wir sind schon
mittendrin, ich glaube wir sollten einfach mal sagen
Hi Kean!
Willkommen zu
034. Das ist 33.
Stimmt.
Nee, welche sind wir?
Ja, das Pad heißt 33 und ich starre da schon so lange drauf,
dass ich jetzt der Teil 34 genannt habe.
Ich nenne das dann später nochmal um.
Ich schaue auf die Webseite, um sicher zu gehen.
Es ist Folge 33 jetzt.
Hi Kilian!
Nein, das lassen wir so drehen.
Ja, ja, ich meine, wenn wir schon so viele
so hohe Nummern erreichen,
dann passiert einem mal so ein Malheur,
dass man mal irgendwie vergisst,
eine Nummer
zu vergessen.
Wir haben uns schon wieder eine Weile nicht gesehen.
Ich muss sagen, wir haben es mal wieder geschafft, es eine ganze Weile
zu vernachlässigen, unseren schönen wöchentlichen
Podcast,
den wir vielleicht einmal alle anderthalb Monate
auch nehmen. Hat man das mal geplant, wöchentlich zu sein?
Das war, glaube ich, am Anfang mal so irgendwie.
Für wahrscheinlich eine Folge.
Aber naja, gut, es ist viel passiert.
Ich meine, die Datenspuren sind schon wieder so lange her,
dass wir fast gar nicht drüber reden müssen.
Schaut euch die Videos an, es waren wieder Datenspuren.
Wir waren da. Wir haben diesmal keine
Interview-Folge gemacht. Das ist korrekt.
Es gab ein paar coole Talks.
Ich stand auch mal kurz auf der Bühne
und habe für ein Meetup, was dann
daraufhin stattfand, Werbung gemacht.
Was war ein Meetup? Unser Rust-Meetup.
Achso. Das war dann
Ende September. Wir wollten eigentlich Ende Oktober
noch eins machen. Ich glaube, wir verpennen gerade die Organisation
schon wieder.
Genau. Und dann gibt es
aber ziemlich sicher wahrscheinlich mindestens
im November wieder eins, wenn
ich das im Oktober auch verpenne. Ich verpenne es immer.
mich in den Google-Kalender einzutragen,
damit es dann auch in This Week in Rust auftaucht.
Achso, das läuft über einen Kalender zusammen.
Genau, aber das ist der Vektor, über den
wir am ehesten Leute rankriegen.
Das letzte Mal kamen
tatsächlich zwei, drei Leute
neu. Wir waren vielleicht zu fünf oder zu sechs.
Das war aber ziemlich cool.
Also bis zu dem Punkt, wo wir dann überlegt haben,
naja, Rust ist ja keine richtige
funktionale Programmiersprache, weil du hast
ja keine Hire, keine Types.
Und dann hat irgendwie Astro
und ich habe seinen Namen vergessen, wie auch immer das behauptet,
hat angefangen, irgendwie ad hoc
eine generische Monade in Rust zu implementieren.
Da habe ich gesagt, gut, okay, es ist halb zwölf,
ich gehe jetzt nach Hause.
Klingt super spannend.
Es klingt durchaus spannend. Ich möchte jetzt nicht anfangen,
bloß weil ich das Wort Monade erwähnt habe,
zu erklären, was eine Monade ist.
Ich finde es allerdings
durchaus nicht unbedingt notwendig,
generische Monaden in Rust zu haben.
So, das ist das,
was passiert ist.
Das ist nicht notwendig.
Alles, was sich implementieren lässt.
Sollte implementiert werden. Wird früher oder später
irgendwann mal
in Rust implementiert werden.
Da kann man
wirklich irgendwas draus machen.
Oder irgendeine...
Alle generischen Konzepte werden zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt
in Rust implementiert sein.
Oder in Go.
Ja, logischerweise in der Sprache, die dieses Konzept
von generischen Sachen nicht mal kennt.
Wow.
Da hatte ich auch schon einen schönen Tweet von
irgendwem. Screenshot von
einem Reddit oder von irgendeinem Stackoverflash.
oder so. Ja,
ich habe mir diese Go-Syndag gesagt,
ich muss sagen, ich finde da überhaupt keine Dokumentation
in deiner Library, die du da hast.
Was ist denn das? Ist das überhaupt?
Ach, der Ticket-Generics in Go?
Da hatte irgendeiner dann, und das auf dem Screen-Train hast du gesehen,
es war eindeutig Go mit Generics und der so,
nee, das ist kein Teil von Go,
mein Pre-Processor macht dann da mehrere
Implementations, das ist quasi ein Template.
Und zwar irgendwelche griechischen Zeichen,
dass das, also statt von spitzen Klammern,
weil spitze Klammern in Identifier-Namen nicht zulässig sind,
Den Typnamen, da waren das irgendwelche griechischen Zeichen,
die aufgrund ihrer Position im ASCII
zulässig sind. Aber es muss ja kein
valides Go sein, weil ja vorher der Pre-Processor drüber ging.
Achso, stimmt. Das müsste gar nicht. Aber vielleicht wollte die
trotzdem eindeutig unterscheiden. Ich habe zumindest dann unten drunter
geschrieben, ich glaube, dass es genau wie C zu seinem
Pre-Processor gekommen ist. Ja, schon Jahre.
Ich glaube, ich war fast alt.
War dieser Post, aber es war nicht sicher.
Wir haben, wie gesagt, leider mal wieder eine Weile nicht...
Ja, wir sind seit Jahren keine Folge aufgenommen.
Nee, nee, die letzte war noch dieses Jahr.
Ja, das war ja noch nicht ganz gewaltt.
Das war mit Stefan, das war hier an diesem Tisch.
Aber an dieser Stelle überlege ich mir jetzt gerade,
wäre es prinzipiell möglich,
den C-Preprocessor
zu missbrauchen, um damit
eigentlich auch Go die gleiche include
und Generics sind da... Ne, es ist mittlerweile
in die Sprache reingewandert.
Ich zähle mich an diesen Typen, der einen Preprocessor,
einen PHP, äh, PHP als Preprocessor
für C genutzt hat.
Das war toll.
Wenn solche Spielereien sind,
sind ja was Feines.
Ich meine, dafür ist es da, ne?
Ich habe ein halbes Jahr lang auf Arbeit an einem Projekt gearbeitet,
wo wir mit Handlebars Code in zwei Programmiersprachen erzeugt haben.
Geil.
Wo es auch nur eigentlich so ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz ist,
dass sobald du irgendwie eine Spielerei anfängst,
gibt es irgendeine Firma, die das in einem Enterprise-Kontext auch nutzt.
Ja.
Also irgendwer nutzt gerade diesen PHP-Präprozessor.
Ach so.
Egal, was für dumme Spielereien existiert.
Was irgendwas zum Spaß stellt, ist auf GitHub und drei Jahre später sagt einer,
oh, könntest du das mal bitte fixen oder updaten, wir benutzen das in unserer Firma.
Irgendein Enterprise-Dings basiert ist darauf.
Hundertprozentig.
Bitte lass es nicht meinem Gut passieren.
Schon zu spät?
Spielt schon gar keine Rolle mehr.
Wenigstens in meiner Firma, dann würde ich dafür bezahlt werden,
das zu fixen oder sowas.
Aber das ist noch nicht passiert.
Was ist denn bei dir so aktuell?
Ich bastel gerade sehr viel an einer iOS-App rum.
Hab damit sehr viel Spaß gehabt.
Ich hatte mir vor kurzem mal SwiftUI zu Gemüte geführt.
Dieses fancy neue UI-Framework von Apple.
Für die aktuelle Plattform von Apple.
ist cool, super cool.
Das ist ein deklaratives UI-Framework.
Und bisher war es bei mir so,
wenn ich eine iOS-App oder wenn ich irgendein Projekt
angefangen habe, dann habe ich immer erst angefangen,
irgendwelche API-Wrapper zu schreiben für Dinge, die das Ding so braucht.
Dann irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, Model-Typen.
Dann schöne APIs, also interne APIs
dafür ausgedacht und implementiert.
Die die UI dann benutzt.
Genau, aber auf die UI hatte ich nie Bock, es hat nie Spaß gemacht.
Und daran sind mal viele Projekte eingeschlafen.
Aber mit SwiftUI macht das
echt super viel Spaß.
Weil es einfach nicht mehr so viel Legwork ist.
Es ist super wenig Code, den du schreiben musst.
Natürlich ist es nicht perfekt
und es gibt auch noch überall in Stellenweise Bugs
und jetzt ist es ein bisschen fraglich, wie die gefixt werden,
weil das Zeug ist ja jetzt released.
Und die Behaviours sind teilweise nicht das, was man erwarten würde
und wirklich buggy.
Echt, ja?
Aber ist es bereits eine 1.0-Version?
Naja, du kannst damit diese Apps in den Store pushen.
Ich meine, es kann ja sein,
dass du demnächst eine Version 2.0 mit API-Jet-Fest ausbringst.
Ja, aber du kannst es ja nicht versionieren.
Wieso kannst du es nicht versionieren?
System Framework ist, was du einfach nur so sagst,
also sie haben
zwei Optionen für die Zukunft, entweder
also, sagen wir mal,
sie haben entweder die Option, alte, bestehende Apps
kaputt zu machen, machen sie eher
weniger, aber das wäre so das Beste
wahrscheinlich dafür, um das zu fixen,
oder sie fixen es
und machen irgendwie
ein Name-Change draus, 50.UI 2,
aber das passiert ja auch nicht.
Weil das quasi als Include... Ja, und sie leben damit.
Ja, gut.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht finden sie da irgendwie eine gute Option.
Trotzdem so oder so, es gibt ein paar Bugs, die sind ein bisschen blöd, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es ein richtig tolles Framework, mit dem du sehr einfach, sehr interessant dir coole UIs zusammenbauen kannst, die alles richtig machen.
Sagen wir es so, also du hast direkt Dark Mode Support, du hast direkt Right-to-Left-Text-Support.
Das mit dem Dark Mode, das hat auch so um sich gegriffen
wie so eine
Krankheit, oder?
Mac hat jetzt Dark Mode,
dann hat Chrome irgendwie
Dark Mode gekriegt oder die Browser
haben angefangen, irgendwie das mit reinzuziehen.
Es gibt eine
HTTP, es gibt jetzt eine Web API,
mit der dein System
der Webseite sagen kann, dass es bitte
in Dark Mode zu sein hat, damit die Webseiten
passend sind. Es gibt auch eine Reihe von Webseiten, die das gut unterstützen,
das finde ich sehr angenehm, weil ich nutze es von Catalina,
kurz gerade leer, diesen neuen Auto-Mode,
dass der bei Sonnenuntergang automatisch switcht, das finde ich sehr
angenehm. Und du hast abends
halt dunkle Interface, auch teilweise dunkle
Webseiten. Ich vermisse immer noch
diese Halb-Halb-Einstellung,
ich möchte eigentlich nicht immer unbedingt Dark-Mode
haben, aber ich finde es schöner, wenn
das
Dock unten im Dark-Mode ist.
Das sollte überhaupt nie
hell werden, muss ich sagen.
Das wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht kriegen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich finde es schön, wenn
man halt...
Viel Erfolg damit.
ich finde es schön, wenn man es halt automatisch ändern kann
weil ich mag den Leitmod auch sehr
aber jedenfalls hatte ich sehr viel Spaß
mit SwissUI, was ich cool finde
an dem Framework ist, dass es halt relativ
plattformagnostisch ist, das spielt jetzt keine Rolle
ob du jetzt, also du schreibst Code nicht spezifisch
für iOS, musst dementsprechend iOS-spezifische
APIs nutzen, also weil es auch auf
WatchOS und
MacOS und iPadOS
und TVOS theoretisch
und EarpodOS
und T-PotOS
und auf deinem Toaster, genau.
Aber theoretisch, also der
Helge hat ja auch schon mal
vorhin erwähnt, jetzt Swift
Web UI geschrieben, wo du theoretisch
halt dasselbe Layout nutzen kannst, um
Web-Dinge zu layouten.
Was cool ist,
weil das Framework an sich halt
keine Assumptions macht auf die Plattform.
Du definierst halt einfach nur,
hier ist eine Liste von Elementen und diese Elemente sind
alle einfach nur ein horizontaler Stack von
Aber es ist trotzdem Swift-Code, den du schreibst.
Im Prinzip, du schreibst es in Swift, ja.
Das ist ein paar cool neue Syntax-Features.
Das Konzept, meine UI-Beschreibungssprache
ist plattformagnostisch,
ist ja jetzt irgendwie
100.000 Jahre alt. Ja, klar. Das ist ja nichts Neues.
Das ist auf jeden Fall. Aber es ist
trotzdem eine sehr schicke API.
Und wie gesagt, das nutzen ein paar coole neue Swift-Sprach-Features,
um das halt sauber umzusetzen.
Das ist halt so eine DSL-like-Defektion.
Redest du da irgendwann mal drüber in Detail?
Ich meine, der Podcast ist jetzt hier keine gute Plattform.
Aber vielleicht irgendwie besser.
Da müsste es ja mal eine Hallo-Swift-Folge drüber geben, oder?
eine Swift-Folge, müsste es mal drüber geben. Oder
einen Talk bei irgendwie Cocoa Heads oder sowas.
Das hatte ich schon geplant vielleicht.
Ich habe auch momentan schon wieder zwei Tech-Talks
in der Pipeline. Ich bin ja
mit diesem WebAssembly-Tech-Talks ein bisschen
auf Tour gegangen in Dresden. Ich habe den erst
in der Firma gehalten. Dann habe ich den bei
zwei
Web
Meetups und einer
und dem Mobile Camp
gehalten, eher zufällig.
Und jetzt momentan
es steht in meinen Jahreszielen, dass ich noch irgendwie
Tech Talk über Web Audio
machen müsste, mindestens.
Da bastle ich gerade so ein bisschen an
einer Demo.
Nice, cool.
Also weil bei uns ja immer an der Firma,
dass die Web Komponente so ein bisschen stiefmütterlich
behandelt wird und ich sage so, naja, eigentlich mit Web Audio
kann man schon extrem viel machen.
Es gibt ein Tech Talk
in einem Vortrag von JSConf EU,
wo einer Gitarreneffekte
in JavaScript gebaut hat.
Das habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt,
Der stand dann halt auf der Bühne mit seiner Gitarre
und hat nicht unbedingt super gut Gitarre gespielt,
aber der Vortrag war ziemlich witzig.
Hast du dann tatsächlich auch so ein cooles Interface,
wo du live Codenipsel zusammenhacken kannst?
Das könnte man tatsächlich als Demo machen,
dass du irgendwie,
die API sieht so aus,
du erzeugst irgendwie einen Kontext
und dann kannst du da unterschiedliche
Audio-Knoten aneinander pipen
und die
auf die einzelnen Frames,
die kriegen die Audio-Frames
einmal kurz durchgereicht.
Genau. Und damit habe ich zum Beispiel
für unsere interne Testpage schon relativ
das ist relativ einfach,
dafür Audiovisualisierungen zu bauen.
Heiß, okay.
Du kannst aber auch, da gibt es eine Demo von RN Noise,
das ist ein Noise Reduction-Dings, was eigentlich in C geschrieben ist.
Das ist nach
SMJS
oder nach WebAssembly zu kompilieren
und dann kannst du es auch im Web machen.
So, das geht.
Tatsächlich eine Demo, wo du sagst, hier guck mal,
ist eine Funktion, da werden alle meine Frames mal dran
vorbeigetragen, kannst du jetzt Eval drücken
das wäre immer schön für die Demo, aber da muss ich noch eine Weile
dran frickeln, bevor ich das halten kann
ich werde das wahrscheinlich so vielleicht eher
Richtung Ende November
oder Dezember dann auf Arbeit mal halten
so als Tech Talk und vielleicht halte ich den dann
in Dresden nochmal bei einem Meetup
Mach mal, würde ich gerne mithören, das ist auf jeden Fall
Spannend
Das andere, was ich jetzt eigentlich noch so in der Pipeline habe, ist, dass ich noch einen über
Rust Web Frameworks halten wollte
Aha, mal ein komplett Abriss
was so der Stand der Dinge ist
Was so gerade geht, genau, es gibt ja irgendwie Rocket ist eine Weile nichts passiert
und dann gibt es aber diese ganzen Sachen,
die auf Hyper und
Tokio aufsetzen, da ist eigentlich
relativ viel passiert.
Ich habe da letztes Mal versucht, irgendwie einen Überblick
zu bekommen und was mit zu basteln, aber
die hatten irgendwie
so viele neue Abstraktionsebenen
eingezogen, ich habe gar keinen Überblick mehr gehabt.
Wo? Sowohl Hyper als auch Tokio,
vor allem Hyper. Ja, also mit Tokio solltest du
glaube ich nicht direkt arbeiten, zumindest nicht, wenn du
nicht was machen möchtest. Direkt wollte ich
gar nicht mit Tokio arbeiten, sondern eigentlich mit Hyper,
aber das war mir schon fast so tief,
überhaupt einen Überblick zu verstehen. Ja, Hyper ist
selbst auch für das Web, für HTTP
relativ roh.
Darauf aufsetzend gibt es dann sowas wie
Warp, was dann
relativ nette API hat. Coole Name.
Ja, Warp. Da gibt es aber schon ein
Haskell-Web-Framework, was genauso heißt.
Das ist ein bisschen unpraktisch.
Aber das ist eigentlich
ziemlich cool, weil da chainst du so Bedingungen
aneinander, wo du sagst, wenn der
erste Pfad so ist
und dann Pfad so und dann ein Query
ja so, dann führe diesen Händler für
diesen Endpunkt aus. Witzig, okay.
Genau. Und da gibt's
irgendwie auch eine, die Abstraktion
für Websockets ist ziemlich schön, weil du kriegst
einfach bloß ein Event für
jetzt gab's ein Upgrade
und dann kriegst du einen rohen Socket an die Hand
und da ist noch überhaupt kein Websocket dahinter,
dann nimmst du dir eine andere abstrakte
Websocket-Library, wo du sagst,
oh, ich hab hier ein Interface, da kann ich drauf lesen und drauf
schreiben, mach mir da mal Websocket
drauf. Könntest du theoretisch mit der
Lib auch Websocket über Serialport
sprechen oder sowas.
Aber ja, sowas würde ich dann in einem
TikTok nochmal, oder in einem Foto.
Weil der Überblick ist jetzt auch,
ich glaube für euch, die hier gerade zuhören, ein bisschen
zusammenhängt.
Das ist so das, was ich gerade so nebenbei ein bisschen mache.
Wir haben Feedback
bekommen. Wir haben Feedback bekommen?
Ja, so an dieser Stelle machen wir eine
Kapitelmarke. Achso, ich war mit
Mensa Dresden noch gar nicht fertig. Du warst mit Mensa Dresden?
Ach Mensch, wisst ihr, wie wir
abweichen immer mit unseren Tangenten.
Um nochmal kurz den Bogen zurückzuschlagen.
Ich habe mit SwiftUI angefangen.
Ich hatte letztens aber
gesehen, also ich habe da erstmal eine kleine Watch-App mit
gebastelt, weil ich einfach mal was Kleines anfassen
wollte. Hatte dann gesehen, dass es nach
Jahren des Wartens endlich
zu einer offiziellen API
des Studentenwerks in Dresden gekommen ist,
wo man Speiseplandaten aus den Mensen
lesen kann. Ist es eine GraphQL
API?
Die ist tatsächlich
der Open Mensa-API nachempfunden, was ich sehr
spannend finde. Der Maintainer
davon meint auch, dass er gerne die Kompatibilität
zu Open Mensa behalten möchte, was
ein bisschen weird ist, weil er die schon kaputt gemacht hat.
Ich wette ja fast, dass er,
ich würde fast Geld drauf wetten, dass er
den Open, also Open Mensa ist so ein Projekt,
die aggregieren
Mensa-Daten aus verschiedenen
deutschen Mensen, ich weiß gerade, ob es nur Deutschland ist,
sogar vielleicht auch mehrere, und geben die einfach
als offene Schnittstelle bereit, stellen die bereit
für Leute, die es haben wollen, was cool ist.
Und die haben halt sich so ein Format ausgedacht, wie sie das machen,
und wie die Requests spezifiziert sind
beziehungsweise das URL-Scheme
und so weiter.
Und die haben so ein paar witzige
Sachen, wie zum Beispiel, dass
die Preise ausgeben und die Preise sind
natürlich im JSON einfach als Dictionary
meistens für, ich glaube, Studenten und Mitarbeiter,
die ja oftmals unterschiedliche Preise haben
und witzigerweise, wenn
die Preise leer sind, also wenn keine Preise bekannt sind,
ist das ein leeres Array, was ich
ekelhaft vom Typen her finde, weil es halt nicht der
gleiche Typ ist und diesen selben
Fehler hat der halt... Was ist entweder eine Zahl
oder ein leeres Array? Entweder ein Dictionary oder
ein Array. Ach, das ist immer kacke.
Sowas ist blöd, weil sowas in Swift halt auch blöd dekodieren lässt.
Er muss halt ein bisschen manuell wieder ran.
Generell einen Typsichern und Sprachen ist sowas
ein bisschen eklig zu dekodieren.
Die haben halt denselben Fehler hier in Dresden eingebaut.
Deswegen würde ich Geld drauf wetten, dass
der Typ einfach selber diesen Open Mensa
Scraper betreibt, der Typ
hier aus Dresden, und die eigene Webseite
scrapt und das dann einfach als
API in Anführungsstrichen
anbietet. Hast du mit dem mal
gequatscht? Ja, aber ich habe ihm noch nicht diesen
Vorwurf quasi unterbreitet.
Vielleicht kommt es ja bald zu einem Treffen.
Was hatte ich aufgrund dieser API dann mal Bock, endlich dafür eine iOS-App
zu schreiben und habe da heute die zweite
Version von in den Store geschoben.
Und diese App kann jetzt endlich auch,
vielen Dank hier an den Typen,
Georg Sieber, ich glaube der arbeitet bei der
Struplats, seinem GitHub-Profil nach, der
quasi Beispielcode bereitgestellt hat
auf GitHub, wie man die Mensa-Karte
der Emil hier in Dresden genannt
oder Emil, ich glaube
Emil tatsächlich. Ich glaube, ja, wie der Name.
Also E-M-E-A-L.
Wie man die NFC-Karte auf iOS scannt.
Und das kann meine App jetzt auch.
Und zusätzlich, wenn du noch die...
Deine Mensa-App kann jetzt sagen, wie viel Geld du noch hast?
Ja. Und wenn du deine
Autoload-Credentials, also wenn du diesen
Autoload-Service nutzt, dass dein Konto automatisch
dir Geld abgezogen wird, wenn deine Mensa-Karte
runtergeht, das ist ja so ein optionales Ding,
dann hast du auch Zugang zu so einem Karten-Service-Portal
des Studentenwerks. Und wenn du
diese Credentials in der App hinterlegst,
die werden natürlich sicher auf dem Gerät gespeichert,
und wann das hingeschickt, logischerweise.
Das sagst du so.
Das heißt, ob du mir was unterstellst.
Wenn du das in der App hinterlegst, dann zeig dir die App auch alle deine letzten Transaktionen mit ein.
Das hat noch keine andere App bisher.
Das ist die coolste Mensa.
Wie viele Mensa-Apps für Dresdner Mensa gibt es denn mittlerweile?
Keine Ahnung, 15, 20?
Wie heißt deine, meine Mensa?
Mensa Dresden. Der Name war frei, wer hätte es gesagt.
Cool.
Aber hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Ich habe mir immer überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einfach mal wieder eine Mensa-Karte holen sollte.
Ich gebe meine nicht her. Ich war heute in der Mensa.
Ich müsste theoretisch auch einfach so eine kriegen.
Und wenn ich sage, ich bin Mitarbeiter, ich brüchte mal.
Man muss ja, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr Mitarbeiter sein. Es gehen ja auch manche Leute
von Firmen, die einfach neben Mensen.
Ich sage, Sonia Systems Leute gehen ja auch Mensen manchmal.
Immer mal externe.
Und wir haben ja auch zwei Mensen in Laufreichweite.
Und da finde ich es immer blöd, wenn ich danach Babel zahle.
Wo sind denn da Mensen?
Ach, die Brühl.
Ja, die von der Kunsthochschule und die von der Musikhochschule.
Stimmt.
Ja, ja, hast recht.
Stimmt. Da war ich noch nicht.
Nee, sind relativ klein.
Aber es ist witzig, wenn da
die Künstler und die Musiker rumhängen.
Ja, nice.
Noch mehr Mensa Dresden?
Nö.
Was hatte ich dann gerade angefangen und abgebrochen?
Wir haben Feedback bekommen.
Ach so, wir haben Feedback bekommen.
Genau, also
erstmal, ich habe natürlich nicht
Akademiker gedisst.
Das möchte ich mir nicht unterstellen lassen.
Überhaupt nicht.
Ja,
War das
Magnesium?
Ja.
Also ich habe ja sehr viele Freunde,
ich habe Freunde, die auch Akademiker sind.
Ich habe auch Akademikerfreunde.
Ich bin ja gar nicht Anti-Akademiker.
Ich wäre ja auch selber gerne manchmal Akademiker,
wenn ich darüber nachdenke, dass ich bloß
mein kleines Diplom habe.
Aber es ist natürlich, ich meine,
das war ein Witz.
Insofern, dass
das Leben als Akademiker natürlich nicht unbedingt
leicht ist, wenn man das nicht über die
auf die leichte Schulter
nehmen sollte.
Und so war es natürlich, ich möchte mich an dieser Stelle
bei allen Akademikern entschuldigen, die ich mit meiner
Aussage eventuell verletzt habe.
Es tut mir sehr leid.
Genau, anderes Feedback, was wir
bekommen haben,
ist, dass wir mal
über nichts reden sollten. Wir reden über so viel,
wir sollten auch mal über nichts reden.
Werden wir nachholen.
Da hat sich zumindest einer,
der sich damit wohl offenbar ganz gut auskennt,
den ich eh schon ziemlich lange
mal im Gespräch haben wollte,
in der Sendung haben wollte, gemeldet,
dass wir mit dem mal über nix reden.
Ich sag jetzt noch nicht wer, aber...
Wir werden über nix reden. Ganz viel nix.
Oh je, oh je.
Habe ich sowas schon mal gemacht,
dass wir irgendwas versprochen haben?
Dann hat Kilian
unseren Feed bei Bitlove
gefixt. Hoffentlich, ich glaube.
Das werden wir sehen,
sobald die nächste Folge online ist.
Achso, man kann den nicht editieren, habe ich gesehen.
Ich habe ihn rausgelöscht.
Was ist mit den alten Folgen dann jetzt?
Die fehlen jetzt, oder haben wir da ein Loch von Folgen?
Das war irgendwie weird.
Also müssen wir dazu erst eine neue Folge veröffentlichen?
Ja, um zu sehen, ob es nicht updatet.
Ah, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Vielleicht geht es auch schon.
Das ist irgendwie drei Wochen,
in dem ich das gefixt habe.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall löschen
und neu hinzufügen oder so.
Und ebenfalls Errata,
und damit hake ich das jetzt hier,
diesen Errata und Updates ab,
Man kann auch in seinem eigenen Wahlkreis Wahlhelfer sein, wurden wir hinterher korrigiert.
Das korrekte Verb heißt Wahlhelfern.
Man kann dort auch Wahlhelfern.
Genau.
Es heißt übrigens nicht Wahlhelfer, sondern Wahlhelfende.
Okay.
Es ist mir aufgefallen, dass jetzt zum Beispiel bei Deutschlandfunk Nova redet man nicht mehr von Forschern,
aber auch nicht von Forscherinnen, sondern von Forschenden.
Ja, so wie Studenten und Studierenden.
Ja, Studentende.
Studentende.
Studente.
Titel.
Okay.
Wir haben noch andere Themen.
Erstmal, was ist das hier überhaupt, was du mir hingelegt hast?
Swag.
What?
Es ist klein und es ist in einer Tüte
und es hat viele, viele Ebenen
und vorne drauf ist ein akronomisierbar Logo.
es sind akronymisierbare Sticker.
Wir haben akronymisierbare Sticker.
Werden sie auf dem Kongress auf jeden Fall mit verteilen.
Wir werden, wenn die auf dem Kongress
noch da sind,
werden wir sie auf dem Kongress verteilen.
Ich werde mal versuchen, meine bei mir zu tragen.
Ihr dürft mich gerne auf der Straße
anquatschen.
Klar doch.
Du kannst auf jeden Fall schon einen auf dem Laptop
kleben.
Ich werde mir nachher auch noch einen auf diesem Laptop kleben.
Tue das.
Aber auf die andere Seite.
Aber ich will ihn nicht auf das Display kleben.
Sehr geil. Wie viele sind das jetzt hier nochmal?
Keine Ahnung. 100? 200?
Du hattest 100 bestellt oder hattest du 200 bestellt?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Das sind 50. Ich glaube, wir hatten 100 bestellt.
Oder so.
Cool.
Sehr cool.
Jetzt haben wir hier akronomisierbar T-Shirts.
Jetzt haben wir noch akronomisierbar Sticker.
Was brauchen wir noch?
Tassen, Mützen, Dosen.
Akronomisierbar again.
Ja.
Nee.
Das wird's, ja.
Was ist noch passiert?
Wir waren bei MinCorrect in Dresden, das ist auch schon wieder
eine ganze Weile her.
Oh Gott, wie alt diese Nachrichten sind.
Das Petty ist nicht mehr auf dem aktuellsten
zeitlichen Stand.
Wir müssen uns mal zusammenreißen mit unserem...
Hast du diesen Blizzard-Fuck-Up mitbekommen?
Was ist denn dieser Blizzard-Fuck-Up?
Die haben,
da war irgendwie ein Interview mit zwei
Blizzard-Moderatoren und einem Gewinner
von
Haarstone irgendwas, nenne ich mich richtig
im Sinne. Und der hat irgendwas
pro Hongkongmäßiges gesagt.
Und was hat er sich getraut?
Das hat er sich getraut. Und blöderweise
hat er ja das in einem Interview mit einer Firma gesagt,
die zu 10% Tencent gehört, oder 5%,
weiß ich gar nicht, oder 15%, irgendwas
in dem Dreh. Und das ist natürlich ganz,
ganz böse. Und Blizzard hat ihm dann
sofort seinen Titel als Gewinner
aberkannt, seine 140.000 Dollar
Preisgeld zurückgenommen,
die beiden Moderatoren gefeuert.
Die beiden Moderatoren gefeuert?
Ja, weil das das Schlimmste ist.
Generell dieses...
Was hätten die machen sollen, den im Mund zu halten, oder was?
Ich glaube, die haben beide irgendwie den Kopf unter den Tisch gehalten,
dass sie kein Teil von dem Statement sein wollten,
aber sind halt lustig quasi drauf eingegangen.
Ich habe es jetzt dafür nicht gesehen gehabt,
aber das ist halt hochgradig bescheuert,
was Blizzard da abzieht.
Das ist die Welt, in der wir leben.
Das ist das, was China jetzt mit dem Rest der Welt macht.
Ja, und wunderschön,
verhalten ich natürlich dann die ganzen
Backlash zu Blizzard online.
Unter anderem haben viele Leute natürlich ihre Accounts auf
diversen Blithard-Dingen gelöscht,
ihre WoW-Accounts und so weiter.
Oh ja, ich werde jetzt nicht mehr WoW spielen, weil
ich habe noch nie WoW gespielt.
Doch, 10 Minuten habe ich mal WoW gespielt.
Aber nicht mit meinem Account.
Das ist lange her. Jedenfalls, was ich super
witzig fand, war, dass anscheinend
versucht wurde, online eine von den
Charakteren aus Overwatch,
glaube ich, zu einem
Symbol für die Hongkong-Proteste zu machen, damit
das ganze Spiel vielleicht verboten wird.
Was super witzig gewesen wäre.
Das ist ein schöner Hack. Das fand ich extrem clever.
Aber Blizzard ist ja jetzt blöderweise
auch nicht mehr alleine mit dem Bullshit. Apple hat ja jetzt
ähnlich was Dummes gemacht und
eine App aus dem Store genommen. Aber da haben sie jetzt auch
in der aktuellen Folge... Das ging auch ein, zwei Mal hin und her.
Ich empfehle, Logbuch und Netzpolitik
dazu zu hören. Das habe ich noch nicht gehört. Ich habe
aus der aktuellen Folge ATP dazu gehört,
wo sie halt auch darauf eingehen, dass Apple halt
in einer beschissenen Lage ist, was das angeht.
Ja, die stellen das Zeug in China auch her.
Da ist dieses Land
deutlich am längeren Ärmel.
Hebel, nicht Ärmel.
längere Ärmel.
Ja, es ist ziemlich
kacke jetzt, wer da hier
den längeren Ärmel hat. Aber es gibt
jetzt eine Alternative.
Zu China.
Es gibt jetzt nämlich, ich habe vergessen, wie sie heißen,
ich werde das mal nachtragen, aber es gibt
jetzt ein Smartphone,
was komplett in Afrika hergestellt
wird. Okay. Und zwar in
Rwanda. Rwanda.
Rwanda Smartphone.
Alternative
zu China.
Hier ist ein Land, was für vieles steht,
aber die Alternative zu China ist,
hey, zieh ein Handy aus einem anderen Land.
Genau, und zwar ist das ein
ein Marathon,
heißen die.
Da ist ein Löwe
als Logo drauf, sieht aus wie ein Smartphone,
ist halt ein Android-Telefon
und ist komplett
in Wonder hergestellt.
Das ist cool.
Ich meine, die seltenen Nerden kommen eh schon aus.
Das ist eines der
ich glaube eines der am höchsten
entwickelten Länder in Afrika auf jeden Fall.
Das heißt bei Wakanda.
Wakanda?
Das ist aus Marvel?
Ja.
Ich finde es geil, dass die
ihre eigenen Smartphones herstellen.
Selbst das Fairphone, wo wird
denn das hergestellt? Weiß ich nicht.
Selbst da kommt keiner aus China, oder?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich
würde es mir nicht wundern.
Also, ich meine,
wenn man mit der Meinung von dem Land
nicht komplett mitgeht
und irgendwie Alternativen und so. Ich glaube nicht, dass man
dieses Telefon in so großen Mengen
kaufen kann, aber es ist halt ein Problem,
dass das alles aus der gleichen Ecke kommt.
Wir haben ja auch wirtschaftlich und
technologisch dementsprechend Nachteile
in anderen Ländern.
Wenn Trump jetzt sagt, leck mich am Arsch,
wir importieren überhaupt nichts mehr aus China,
dann gibt es halt keine Smartphones mehr für die Amerikaner.
Überhaupt nicht.
Ja, das wäre sicherlich spaßig.
Ich meine, das, was eben mit seinen
Terroristen...
müsste dann irgendwie aus Korea oder sowas kommen.
Was macht der aktuell?
Der hat jetzt auch so ein Gewissen, dass Adobe
venezuelanische
Accounts aus diesem Land
löscht, weil die
nicht mehr
quasi mit dem
Land im Handel sein dürfen.
Dann gab es ja diesen ganzen Iran-Fuck-Up.
Es gab diesen GitHub-Fuck-Up.
Ja, ist ja kein Fuck-Up. Ich meine, sie müssen halt
complinen, was halt aber super bitter ist.
Dass du, also
Was für eine Zeit leben wir denn?
Ja, das Mittelalter
kommt zurück.
Das ist lächerlich. Was haben die im Mittelalter gemacht,
dass die Gittert nicht mehr nutzen durften?
Ich glaube, dann sind die auf die Felder gegangen
und haben Hirse angebaut.
Nee, ist aber echt traurig.
Und so gut gebetet und so.
Ja, na, wir können bloß hoffen, dass das irgendwie
diese Phase, in der wir
momentan uns befinden, seit 2016,
seitdem irgendwie Brexit beschlossen
und Trump gewählt wurde
und der allgemeine Rechtsruck
Was ist das hier für ein Stammtischgespräch?
Ja, aber es ist ja ein Problem.
Wie geht das jetzt in Hongkong aus?
Hoffentlich kommen die ja noch auf den Grünen.
Pass ja auf, dass du dich jetzt hier nicht zu Hongkong
in der Position ziehst.
Ja, keine Ahnung, es ist scheißegal, ob die chinesische Regierung
akronomisierbar verbietet.
Da wirst du von akronomisierbar gefeuert.
Wie gesagt, die NFL hat jetzt auch so ein Riesending.
Ah ja, weil
die Chinesen gerne
Basketball schauen.
Das ist auch irgendwie,
wird nicht mehr ausgestrahlt.
Da werden Spiele von einer Mannschaft
nicht mehr gezeigt, deren Trainer
sich pro Hongkong gezeigt hat.
Das ist lächerlich.
Können die mal so einen arabischen Frühling endlich
hinkriegen? Hoffentlich.
Das Problem ist ja auch, dass...
Gehen ja nicht schon jeden Tag
Hunderttausende von Menschen auf die Straße.
Aber das ist halt Hongkong.
Hongkong ist halt
hoffentlich noch so ein eigenständiges Ding.
Dafür kämpfen sie ja gerade.
Ja, eben.
Aber das ist ja nicht Mainland China, was hier
auf die Straßen geht und protestiert.
Gab es da nicht neulich erst ein gutes Last Week Tonight
zum Thema... Sicherlich.
Ja, genau.
Beziehungsweise meine ich auch, es gab irgendeine
längere Podcast-Folge zu irgendeiner
fuck, was war denn das für ein Podcast?
Shit, komme ich nicht mehr drauf.
Vielleicht fährt man noch einen.
Tun wir dann einfach in die Show Notes.
Wollen wir mal wieder
umschwenken? Ja.
Und zwar...
Was waren denn noch so Themen, die wir hier hatten?
Also was ich vorhin zu
Warp erzählt hat, ich hab mich gerade noch mal gewundert,
es ist schwierig, von so einem Thema wieder wegzukommen.
Ja, was wir ja auch für Themen in der Liste
haben. Richard Stormont steht hier,
ist auch schon ewig her, aber
Richard Stormont ist von der FSF
zurückgetreten,
als Chairman, weil er
sich scheiße geäußert hat.
Und möchte aber weiter
schief nüßens bleiben.
Genüßens bleiben.
Und es gibt dann Leute, die sagen,
ach nee, jetzt ist der immer noch bei Genug.
Zombie.
die Gesellschaft,
manche Ecken werden mehr woke
und sagen, nee, bloß weil du warst
auch nicht cool,
dass so Leute an Sachen, die sie vor 40 Jahren
vielleicht mal gesagt haben, gemessen werden.
als
40 Jahren war der gesamte,
war alles sexistischer.
Ja, aber ich meine, das macht es nicht besser,
aber es ist auch trotzdem,
es ist auch nicht alles, ja, es macht es nicht.
Es ist trotzdem richtig, dass,
also da gab es auch eine coole Radiolab-Folge vor kurzem
Right to be forgotten hieß die, glaube ich.
Genau, die habe ich gehört, ja.
Wo es irgendwie darum geht, dass du halt, wenn du einmal in den Medien warst wegen irgendwas,
auch wenn es was Dummes war, das hängt dir halt für immer nach.
Und jeder wird, mit dem deinen Namen googelt, stolpert darüber.
Und irgendwann ist halt auch eigentlich Schluss.
Also je nach, also müsste halt irgendwie, die haben da, glaube ich, Dinge bewertet.
Journalisten haben ihre eigenen Online-Angebote durchgegangen, haben immer wieder beschlossen.
Ist das hier verjährt genug, als dass wir das löschen können,
dass wir diese Person von diesem Schatten quasi befreien?
Oder ist das so schlimm, dass das halt noch online bleiben sollte?
Es ist gar keine einfache Frage, aber ich finde zumindest den Gedanken toll, dass man halt drüber spricht, ob das Dinge halt verschwinden können.
Ja, ja, ja.
Was ich schlimm finde, in der Situation, ich glaube, das ist was wir in Deutschland nicht ganz so sehr haben, ist, dass die Nachrichten, die Nachrichtenblätter zumindest,
wahrscheinlich auch die Online-Nachrichten in den USA, viel häufiger die Klarnamen von Leuten verwenden.
In Deutschland hörst du bloß Stefan B.
Stimmt, das ist eigentlich so...
Also in Deutschland ist es sehr untypisch, dass du die Nachnamen von
irgendwelchen Tätern hörst.
Oder von Opfern. Du hörst nie
die vollständigen Namen. Die Leute sind
fast immer
verpixelt oder unkenntlich
gemacht. Es gibt diesen schönen Subred
Florida Man, wo
also wenn halt, wenn sie nicht
den Namen publishen, sondern einfach nur
man von Florida.
Wenn es irgendwen aus Florida gibt und der Subred
trägt halt diesen Titel, weil es halt angeblich
der bescheuerste Superhero aller Zeiten
Florida Man.
Der halt nur, also keine Ahnung,
der halt nackt heulend durch die Kante
rennt einen Polizisten beleidigt oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Zu Hause wird Alligatoren catcht.
Den Subway gibt es auch auf Deutsch, der heißt Mann aus Sachsen.
Oh nein, das könnten wir beide sein.
Hoffentlich nicht.
Die Hälfte unserer Hörer.
Tja.
Tja, akronomisierbar.
Tagesgeschichte und Politik.
Bald gibt es übrigens Congress-Tickets.
Gute Nachrichten.
Gehst du zum Kongress?
Ich hoffe sehr.
Die Karte muss natürlich funktionieren, aber ich hoffe doch.
Und dann bin ich auf dieses Jahr auf jeden Fall wieder dabei.
Sehr gut.
Vielleicht kriegen wir diesmal
gemeinsam eine Folge
vom Sendegate
hin, wo du mit am Tisch sitzt.
Sendegate?
Du warst bei beiden Kongress-Sendungen
nicht dabei. Doch, doch. Bei der ersten war ich dabei.
Bei der zweiten konntest du nicht.
Bei der letztes Jahr war ich nicht dabei.
Da war ich physisch nicht vor Ort.
Dafür hatten wir dann Julian, der quasi
wir stellen, finde ich.
Ja, aber wir würden gerne
euch auch mal kennenlernen
auf dem Kongress, wenn
ihr den kommen wollt. Auf jeden Fall, also wir sind beim
Kongress, wir werden Sticker dabei haben, also
wenn bis dahin noch welche übrig sind, es kann natürlich auch sein,
dass ich mir die hier überall hinklebe, mein Kühlschrank ist groß.
Und ich meine, das hat jetzt auch nicht so lange gedauert,
die zu bestellen.
Aber es hat ein bisschen Geld gekostet.
Bestell mal nach.
Und dann stellen wir uns da hin,
müssen endlich mal unsere Akronomie-Sieber-T-Shirts
dort anziehen.
In der Tat.
Und dann schütteln wir mal Hände.
Wie sieht es momentan mit unseren Hörerzahlen aus?
Wir haben irgendwie 100 Downloads pro Folge.
Um den Dreh, genau.
Das sind natürlich 60 von dir
und nochmal 20, 30 von mir.
Ja, immer die Folge löscht
und Neurotter lädst.
Ja, schön.
Wir müssen ja irgendwo die Zahlen herbekommen.
Hast du was am Hektobofest gemacht?
Ja, ich wollte noch eigentlich ein paar Sachen machen, hatte aber dann noch keine Zeit dafür.
Also ich werde es wahrscheinlich dieses Jahr wieder nicht machen.
Ich muss mal kurz schauen auf aktorfest.digitalocean.com.
Oh, ich habe schon vier gemacht.
Ich wollte aber noch andere Sachen machen.
Ah ja, also da kriegst du schon mal dein T-Shirt.
Drei von den vier sind einfach nur dumme hier.
Ich füge mal schnell dieses Element, diesem Jason hinzu.
Ich wollte noch irgendwas Sinnvolles machen, sonst muss ich mich ja schlecht fühlen.
Also ich habe immer irgendwie Seiten
oder Kapitel in dem Rust-Book
auf Deutsch übersetzt, bei dieser Rustlang.de
Geschichte. Auch witzig.
Das war dann, jeder Kapitel war ein PR
und dann hatte ich das jedes Mal vorher.
Letztes Jahr habe ich zum Beispiel kein T-Shirt gekriegt, weil ich
nicht mitgemacht habe. Das war echt schick.
Ich habe leider auch letztes Jahr nicht mitgemacht.
Schade. Aber das läuft.
Ich meine, es ist ja Freitag erst, ne? Ja, es läuft auch noch.
Wir haben noch hier fast einen halben Monat.
Also, wenn ihr wollt, tragt mich beim Hectorfest
noch ein. Macht irgendwas.
Auf jeden Fall. Es gibt so viele coole Sachen da draußen.
breitet die Liebe von Pull Request,
committed zahlreich.
Hast du schon mal was,
weil ich vorhin gefragt habe zum Thema Mensa-App
und GraphQL, hast du schon mal gegen
GraphQL was gemacht
von einer iOS-App aus?
Habe ich,
aber das war jetzt nicht irgendwie
hier Kraftfeatures von GraphQL nutzen,
sondern ich habe mir die Query rausgesucht
gegen die API, die ich haben wollte
und habe die dann halt mit
zwei substituten Parametern
gehardcoded als langes String-Literal
und dann die Query abgeschickt.
Und nicht irgendwie irgendwas benutzt, was
das Lokal mir hier wirklich die Queries dynamisch
machen kann. Und da habe ich aber auch
keinen Bedarf zu gehabt in dem Use Case.
Aber das muss man auch
nicht. Weil ich hier eine
Leseempfehlung gerade gesehen habe, die ich
auch irgendwie gestern oder vorgestern gesehen habe.
Und zwar ist das
Headless CMS
REST vs.
JSON API vs. GraphQL.
Okay.
Und das ist, weil
jetzt, wir hatten neulich
ein Tech Talk zum Thema Jamstack gesehen,
es gibt viel mehr
Services, die dazu übergehen,
einfach einen Headless-Service oder nur noch eine
API anzubieten und den Rest komplett im Frontend
zu machen oder eine Frontend-Server
zu haben, der das unabhängig davon
macht. Okay.
Und Rest ist
ein bisschen wenig dafür
und GraphQL ist aber auch schon wieder ganz schön
ein ganz schöner Klopper, so als
Alternative dazu.
Und hier gibt es einen Blogpost, der ist,
ach, hier steht es sogar auf der Seite selber,
das ist ein 11-Minuten-Leseaufwand.
Eine schöne tabellarische Nebeneinanderstellung
zwischen Pu und REST, GraphQL und dazwischen JSON-API.
Was ist das nochmal? JSON-API?
JSON-API ist eigentlich ein Aufsatz auf REST.
Ist das wie dieses Hypermedia-Dings?
Genau, ich bin jetzt nicht equipped genau zu erklären,
was JSON-API ist,
aber es gibt eine schöne Spezifikation davon,
da stecken glaube ich auch. Ja, aber ist das das Ding,
was dir halt immer solche extra Links mit dazu hat
und hier kriegst du mehr dazu unter
URL, hier weiterer Pfad
und dann kannst du komplett die API
exploren quasi aus einem Request heraus? Genau.
Das finde ich überhaupt nicht geil.
Dann liest
ihr doch mal diesen Artikel durch.
Werde ich mal machen.
Ich möchte fast überhaupt besser weg als GraphQL.
Sogar, weil es einfach
nicht wie GraphQL ein kompletter
Abkehr von den existierenden
Konzepten ist. Schaut, das ist eine Seite, die unterstützt übrigens Dark Mode.
Die ist bei mir weiß.
Oh, tatsächlich.
Weil ich gerade permanent im Dark Mode
bin. Nicht schlecht.
Ist übrigens
eine Drupa-Seite.
Aber ich habe heute mal nach
anderen Meetups gesucht. Ah ja, pass auf.
Also das ist wieder ein interessantes Thema.
Die gerade ist voll unterbrochen, aber okay.
Wo waren wir gerade?
Den Stack anweinden können wir später
wieder zu hier, REST, JSON-AP, GraphQL.
Achso, ich habe nicht mehr dazu zu erzählen,
das ist mehr so eine Leseempfehlung, weil ich leider noch nicht
dazu gekommen bin, das zu lesen. Ich habe mir ein bisschen die Tabellen
angeguckt und ich hatte immer, wenn ich überlege,
wenn ich jetzt das nächste Dings baue, mache ich da,
weil REST zu bauen ist ja wirklich
einfach und GraphQL,
welche, welche, welche, welche Anziehung
wie man das selber baut.
Ich habe es bisher nur gemacht
über so ein Tool, was mir aufgrund, auf Basis von
einer Postgres-Datenbank, die ist halt komplett inspekted,
das halt automatisch die GraphQL-Lehr
anbietet, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich das selber bauen würde.
Dazu gibt es einen ganz schönen Vortrag von der JS-Context, den hätte ich glaube ich in der letzten Folge schon mal erwähnt, den nehme ich einfach nochmal mit in die Show Notes rein.
Was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte, genau, wir versuchen gerade ein Meetup in Dresden zu hijacken von Arbeit aus.
Was ist das denn?
Und zwar, wir haben in unserem Firmenbüro jetzt schon einmal mindestens, ja einmal das C++ Meetup, C++ User Group Dresden gehostet.
Weil wir so einen schönen großen
Warst du schon mal in unserem Büro drin?
Nur mal kurz.
Wir haben zumindest so eine schöne
große Küche mit so ganz gut um die Ecke
sitzen und wir wollen da mehr Meetups drin haben.
Wir hatten jetzt schon mal das C++ Meetup zu Besuch.
Im November werden wir das nochmal zu Besuch
haben. Und was wir jetzt gerade überlegen,
es gibt eine Konferenz in San Francisco, die heißt
Cranky Geek. Die ist so
WebRTC zentrisch,
wo alle möglichen Leute über wie benutzen
WebRTC reden. Das passt ja zu euch.
Und das passt ziemlich gut zu uns.
Theoretisch habe ich überlegt, eigentlich könnten wir da auch mal
irgendwie einen Vortrag für machen.
Was wir machen werden, ist, dass wir das remote gucken.
Entweder, wenn es mit dem Tag hinhaut,
das wird es wahrscheinlich nicht klappen,
aber werden wir dann bei uns im Büro
irgendwie so ein lokales Meetup machen
und noch ein paar Worte erzählen
und dann einfach die Talks von da gucken
und dabei ein bisschen Bier aufmachen oder sowas.
Und weil wir nicht wirklich eine gute Plattform haben,
wie wir dafür Werbung machen,
Habe ich jetzt mal gefragt beim Webmontag,
ob die vielleicht uns das
als
Webmontag oder sowas machen und dann
das bei uns einfach stattfinden lassen im Büro.
Witzig. Ihr habt nicht so fällig iOS-Entwickler
bei euch, oder? Dass man Koko jetzt mal zu euch ziehen könnte.
Das tatsächlich
leider gar nicht.
Wir suchen allerdings
Entwickler.
Keine
iOS oder
Mac-Entwickler leider,
aber C++
und C++ Backend
und C++ Audio und
vor allem C++
C++ Sternchen hier.
Und JavaScript Webentwickler.
Krass.
Also wenn jemand in Dresden in einer
sehr schönen Lage einen Job sucht.
Auf welcher Werbung.
Irgendwann
musste ich das mal erwähnen.
Da habe ich schon länger mal überlegt, weil
ich bin immer so am Rufragen. Ein paar Stellen sind frei
und es gibt irgendwie echt
so viel zu tun, dass du denkst,
muss ich jetzt mal einfach schamlos
plagen.
Du suchst einen Job als JavaScript-Webentwickler
oder C++-Entwickler.
Schreib mich mal auf Twitter
an und ich mach mal Kontakt.
Ist cool.
Und das darfst du jetzt offiziell auch machen, wenn du magst.
Wenn ihr lieber
suchen wir dann.
Wenn ihr lieber Android-Apps für den
ÖPNV-Bereich machen wollt, kommt mal
auf mich zu.
Da brauchen wir Leute.
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir das auch für die nächsten paar Folgen aus dem Weg.
dann müssen es nicht so weit nochmal machen.
Genau.
Was hast du denn so für GitHub-Stars?
GitHub-Stars, du hast
eine ganze Reihe von Sachen aufgestellt. Fang du doch mal an.
Das sind irgendwie vielleicht 10 Links
von dir hier.
Oh ja, also eine coole Entwicklung,
die ich in den letzten
Wochen verfolge, ist
ein Projekt, das nennt sich Async-STD,
weil jetzt in der nächsten Rust-Version
STD ist für mich eher
Sexually Transmitted Disease.
und das ganze Asynchron klingt sehr beängstigend.
Dann ist es gut,
dass du kein Zplus-Entwickler bist.
Das ist nämlich alles voll STDs.
Das passt zur Sprache.
Aber auch in Rust ist halt
die Standardbibliothek abgekürzt STD.
C heißt das doch Studio.
Punkt H.
Nee, STDIO.H.
Ja, Studio.H.
Ich habe mich mal gefragt, was die Leute,
die nicht aus dem Programmierkontext kommen
oder aus dem Zplus-Kontext kommen
in.io
Domains rein interpretieren.
Ich werde oft gefragt, wenn ich meine E-Mail-Adresse
für miatkir.io irgendwo angehe,
was ist das denn?
Indischer Ozean, wahlfrei.
Echt? Ist das Indischer Ozean?
Io ist halt offiziell Indischer Ozean.
Na, geil.
Zumindest dadurch, dass
in Rust
passiert gerade relativ viel im Bereich
Async-IO.
In der nächsten Version wird
Async-Await-Syntax stabil sein.
auf jeden Fall. Ist es aktuell mehr als das Makro schon?
Es wird kein Makro mehr sein.
Aber es gibt wirklich Syntax dafür. Es gibt dann Syntax dafür.
Und es ist auch ziemlich geil. Also okay.
Vielleicht ist das ein Thema.
Rust bekommt Async-Await-Syntax.
Und zwar,
ich meine,
ich weiß nicht, ob du mal TypeScript gesehen hast, aber TypeScript ist
eine Art und Weise, wie du...
Also, JavaScript selber
hat eigentlich eine recht gute Async-Await-Story,
möchte ich behaupten.
C-Sharp auch, aber ich kenne leider
kein C-Sharp, ich kann jetzt nicht drüber reden.
Und in JavaScript ist es so
und bei TypeScript ist es dann so, dass
du die Signaturen von
Funktionen angibst.
Wenn du jetzt eine Funktion hast, die du async machst,
ist sofort der Rückgabewert,
den du vorher da dran stehen hattest, falsch,
weil du plötzlich angeben musst, dass du
ein Promise zurückgibst. Das ist ein Rust-Anlass.
Du kannst eine Funktion haben, die heißt
add123 und du gibst als Wert
eine Zahl zurück und du schreibst async davor,
kannst du immer noch hinten Zahl stehen lassen.
Das ist so eine Inkonsistenz.
Das finde ich aber keiler. Das ist eigentlich auch ein bisschen
cooler irgendwie, weil es ist einfach die
Funktion async fertig.
Da musst du dir also keinen Kopf drüber machen, aber
technisch gesehen gibt
die Funktion dann in Promise oder in
Rust in Future. Das ist ja völlig richtig so,
aber das willst du ja nicht Typen extra dran schreiben.
Genau.
Was in Rust auch noch anders
ist als bei JavaScript, ist, dass du kein
await-keyword hast, das du vorne
dran schreibst, sodass du sagst,
unser Beispiel
ist jetzt sum equals
await at 1, 2.
Das ist ja eine Funktion auf der Future dann, oder was?
Das ist ein, das ist was Neues,
das ist keine Funktion, du sagst nicht
Punkt await, Klammer auf, Klammer zu, sondern das ist
ein Suffix
Operator.
Und zwar sagst du einfach
Punkt await auf dem Ding
hinten dran.
Und ich hab mir erst gedacht,
was?
Und es ist auch tatsächlich sehr ungewohnt.
Und dann schaust du dir aber noch irgendwie
JavaScript-Code fünfmal an, wo du
auf was, wo du
darauf wartest, chainst,
wo du da eine Klammer drumherum schreibst, damit du
vorne await schreiben kannst und hinter der
geschlossenen Klammer dann mit Punkt weitermachst,
damit du das await aus dem Weg geräumt hast.
Das ist ein Argument, dass man das
Keyword vorher nicht haben will, aber warum
das Suffix statt einer Funktion
auf dem Type?
Weil das keine Funktion auf dem Ding ist.
await ist,
kannst du nicht als Funktion ausdrücken,
auf die Art und Weise. Await verändert ja tatsächlich,
was ein Await oder Async Await
macht, ist, dass er tatsächlich
die Funktion, in der du gerade bist,
deswegen geht es nur in Async-Funktion,
quasi scope-mäßig in der Mitte durchreißt
und den unteren Teil zu einem
weiteren Aufruf
macht, der irgendwann später gescheduled wird,
wenn dieses eine Await-Aufruf,
den du hast, irgendwann mal wieder
aufgeweckt wird. Warte mal, Await muss doch eigentlich blocken.
Await macht doch nicht irgendwie...
Nee, es blockt ja gerade nicht.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Haha, sehr gut.
Also was,
wenn du dir,
das ist ein schönes Thema für einen Podcast,
weil man es überhaupt nicht gut einfach
nur mit Sprache ausdrücken kann, aber wenn du
eine Funktion hast, die irgendwie
innen drin
oder eine Zahl von
Asynchronaufrufen machst,
und du da drin,
wenn du nur Promises verwendest, ich bin jetzt in JavaScript,
dann hast du diese Wenn-Funktion,
wo du eine
Closure reinsteckst, eine Funktion reinsteckst.
Und damit schachtelst du dann tiefer und tiefer und tiefer und tiefer.
Ja.
Und in JavaScript kam dann Async Await und dann kannst du einfach Await davor schreiben und dann kriegst du irgendwie den Wert raus und dann schreibst du den in eine Variable.
Wo ich mir dann immer gedacht habe, das ist eigentlich nicht schön, dass ich das in eine Variable zwischenspeichern muss.
Deswegen siehst du auch manchmal einfach anstatt ich mache einen Promise drauf, machen Leute dann einfach um dieses Ding drumherum klammern, schreiben innerhalb der Klammer und Await und machen dann...
Anyway, wenn du das jetzt mit,
wenn du von Promises
zu Async Await übergehst,
ist ja quasi, deine Funktion
selber darf ja auch nicht blocken.
Das heißt, jede Funktion, in der du Await machst,
muss selber Async sein.
Und das sorgt dafür,
dass du selber dann
ein Promise zurückgibst,
selbst ein Void Promise zum Beispiel.
Und was eigentlich
passiert ist, dass deine Funktion bis zu dem Punkt,
wo du Awaitest, ausgeführt wird,
dann der Scope quasi,
also nicht wirklich Scope,
in den Teil, auf den du wartest, übergeht
und deine Funktion quasi erstmal weggelegt wird,
was bei JavaScript auf dem Event-Loop
bist du dann erst bei der nächsten Iteration wieder dran,
bis dieses Ding,
was du erwähntest,
resolvt und dann geht deine Funktion selber erst weiter.
Okay, ja.
Das reißt deine Funktion quasi
in der Mitte durch.
Hat in JavaScript den witzigen...
Hat er den selten Effekt, oder?
Ja, deswegen musst du das auch gar nicht
so genau verstanden haben, wenn du es benutzt.
Aber du musst,
also das ist zumindest der Grund dafür,
warum du Async-Await,
du möchtest nicht das Async verwenden,
du möchtest das Await verwenden und das Async,
was du an deine Funktion außen dran schreiben musst,
ist das notwendige Übel.
Okay, so kann man es auch betroffen.
Mit Promises kannst du auch Fire- und Forget-Promises
machen in JavaScript, dass du sagst,
ich mache jetzt hier ein Then und du schreibst da irgendwas
rein und danach kann meine Funktion
zu Ende sein. Das passiert irgendwie.
Das würde in Rust
zum Beispiel gar nicht gehen, weil
dann deine Funktion,
dein Promise
wird halt weggeräumt und dann wird es nie
resolved oder es geht halt aus dem Scope und ist weg.
Und ja,
es ist in
Rust haben sie ja zumindest auch
Async Awaits und das ist ein ganz schöner Hub.
Aber ich finde es eigentlich
schön, dass man ein Suffix hat,
weil es nicht encouraged, dass man ständig
zwischendurch neue Variablen
anlegt und das Ergebnis von
immer Wait immer eine Variable speichert.
finde ich irgendwie angenehm.
Ich finde, ich finde es optisch noch nicht
im Kopf ansprechend, muss ich sagen.
Ich lade dir mal ein paar Beispiele aus
dieser ASIC-STD weiter.
Was zumindest jetzt ein Projekt gibt, ist
aus dem Hause
Ferris Systems. Das ist die Firma
von Florian Gilcher, der bei uns jetzt im Besuch war.
Die machen relativ viel
in dem Bereich und stellen einfach auch
Leute an, die aktiv
an der
Codebase weiterarbeiten und das
Projekt heißt Async-SDD, was quasi
die Standardbibliothek von
Rust ist, plus alles Async.
Also alles, was Async sein kann
oder muss, ist plötzlich Async.
Das läuft häufig darauf hinaus, dass
sie einfach Task-Wrapper
um normale Aufrufe drum herum machen, dass sie sich
die Datei aufmachen, machen sie einfach einen Aufruf
drauf, dass du das in der Task, diesen Aufruf,
der sieht dann komplett identisch aus,
aber was du zurückbekommst ist ein Future
was dann einfach von deiner Runtime
wo auch immer deine Runtime, was auch immer deine Runtime ist
weggeschedult werden kann
und du weitermachen kannst
das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich cooles Projekt
und das wollte ich eigentlich bloß mal kurz erwähnen
ich hab selber noch nicht damit rumgespielt, ich wollte zum Beispiel
ich hab hier diese
Notification Library, wo ich
womit du so Desktop Notifications
auf Linux absetzen kannst
und da hab ich auch schon lange
eine Sache, die mir
unter den Fingernägeln brennt,
ist, dass ich einen Funktionsruf drauf habe.
Du kannst in diesen Desktop-Notifications
auf Linux auch Buttons anzeigen
und Aktionen finden. Das heißt, ich kann da
schreiben, ich mache da jetzt fünf Buttons drauf
und je nachdem, welchen
ich anklicke, kommt eine andere Aktion.
Wie ich das momentan implementiert habe
oder nur implementieren kann, ist komplett Blocking.
Okay.
Ich kann also nicht sagen, ich mache dieses Ding
jetzt asynchron. Das habe ich mal
versucht, irgendwie auch als Async-SED
die rauskam, aber die Library,
die ich benutze, diese
DBUS-Library, das ist ja eine
DBUS-API, ist
nicht so gebaut, dass ich da ohne weiteres
die Aufrufe in
Tasks auslagern kann,
weil das ganze Ding inherent nicht
sehr safe ist.
Klingt spaßig.
Der Typ, der DBUS-RS baut,
arbeitet jetzt auch daran,
irgendwie asynchrone APS,
das ist natürlich ein Aufruf auf einem Bus,
Du könntest es quasi auch als Netzwerk-Interface
interpretieren.
Das Ding wird wahrscheinlich demnächst auch
Async-APIs bekommen. Da freue ich mich schon drauf.
Das wird bestimmt ganz cool.
Hat eh ein bisschen komische API an sich.
Die könnte eh ein bisschen hübscher werden.
Das war jetzt ein bisschen
auslagern.
Ne, ausweidend.
Ausweidend?
Das war etwas
ausufernd.
Das war jetzt ein bisschen ausufernd, aber das war jetzt
mein Star Async-STD
gemeint, verfolgt mal die
Async und
Async-Await-Story von Rust.
Das ist ein sehr spannendes Thema zur Zeit.
Ich freue mich, dass jetzt sein Ende findet.
Also die nächste Version müsste irgendwie in ein paar Wochen rauskommen
und ist dann Async-Await drin.
Ich freue mich schon drauf.
Du bist dran. Ich habe mir
ein Projekt herausgesucht, das heißt
Mini Tokyo 3D,
weil es genau das ist.
Es ist Tokyo Klein in 3D.
Cool.
Ist eine Webkarte,
von Real-Time 3D
Tokios Public Transport System.
Und ist einfach super fancy.
Ich würde das gerne mal adoptieren
für andere Städte.
Aber ist das nicht quasi schon
Google Maps einfach?
Naja, die Karte, klar, aber die Daten musst du halt noch irgendwo rankriegen.
Aber gibt es nicht bereits
ÖPNV-Daten in Google Maps?
Ja, Google hat
GTFS-Daten, die sie bekommen.
Und nur das bindet Google ja auch ein.
Achso, der sagt ja nicht, welcher Zug gerade wo ist.
Nee, also GTFS
Realtime sagt ja noch genauere Abfahrtszeiten,
also aktuelle Abfahrtszeiten.
Aber es gibt trotzdem, soweit ich weiß,
keine Positionsdaten gibt es, glaube ich, nicht in GTA.
Könnte mich aber auch täuschen. Aber
das ist, glaube ich, nicht das, was hier benutzt wird,
sondern der bindet das direkt irgendwo anders mit ein.
Aber das Coole ist halt auch, abgesehen davon, dass es
eine coole Karte ist mit einer
fancy Anzeige, dass der halt
auch zum Beispiel Flugzeug mit drin hat, live.
Die sehen ein bisschen
aus wie die Hühnchen bei Minecraft, aber
sehr passend. Aber ich fände es halt geil, weil es halt wirklich
alle ÖPNV
Möglichkeiten hier in Tokio sind auf einer schicken
Karte in Realtime. Es gab ja mal dieses
coole Tool. Das ist mit mir ganz so meine
Bookmarked Town Tools.
Ist das dieses Travic? Genau.
Tracker.gops.ch
Die haben
eine Webseite, wo sie quasi für
gefühlt die Welt,
aber auf jeden Fall große Teile
Europas. Oh ja.
Naja, Deutschland auf jeden Fall
ziemlich krass. In anderen Ländern
sieht es ein bisschen enger aus. UK ist ja noch
in Frankreich gut vertreten. Also sieht aus, als ob
Deutschland ist. Aber die haben halt hier
komplett Daten von allen ÖPNV-Daten,
die sie so haben. Und das ist halt
Live-Position. Das Witzige ist,
die Daten sind halt nicht live, die Daten sind
interpoliert aus den Farbland-Daten.
Also es ist genauso zuverlässig wie ÖFI quasi.
Genau, das ist null zuverlässig hier.
Aber es ist cool, weil du die ganzen Pfade von allem siehst
und du kannst halt wirklich gerade
was anklicken. Wo müsste theoretisch
gerade die 85 sein, wenn sie sich an den Farbland halten?
Genau, und sowas hätte ich auch gerne in meiner
Upcoming-ÖPNV-App,
die ich jetzt dank Studio I wieder angefangen habe,
dass du halt auch so querying
kannst von wegen, hier, wo bleibt mein Bus?
Und dann findet er raus,
da, kommt nicht oder fällt
aus, weil hier sind aktuelle
Daten oder der müsste dort sein.
Nice.
Bei mir lebt die Seite gerade nicht ordentlich, sonst könnte ich dir
anzeigen, wo diese 63 hier noch langfährt, die ich gerade
angeklickt habe. Aber prinzipiell
ich finde das ein richtig cooles Ding und ich würde das
gerne mit mehr aktuellen
Daten sehen. Und generell habe ich dieses
Tugging auch sehr gefallen, weil es
sehr schick ist. Also allgemein, wenn es eine
API gäbe, wo du sagen könntest, wo ist denn
mein Bus jetzt gerade?
Ja, es hat ja schon mal hier...
Es muss ja nicht meine Kartenvisualisierung sein, aber...
Jetzt kann ich doch mal hier jemanden featuren,
der hatte schon mal eine App geschrieben.
Die App heißt Money, so wie
Busfahrer auf Jodel benannt werden.
Achso.
M-A-N-N-I.
Die App zeigt dir
quasi
deine App...
Du hast fünf Screenshots, die du in der Play Store oder Apple App Store Ansicht haben kannst,
die das Format von deinem Handy haben.
Und das sind einfach immer zerhackte Breitbilder.
Das ist schon recht witzig.
Aber du hast hier eine Haltestelle, du klickst irgendwas an.
Das sieht doch aus wie Jode.
Und der sagt dir dann auf der Karte, wo diese Verbindung gerade jetzt ist.
Also sein müsste, wenn sie sich an den Fahrplan halten.
Genau, also der sagt dir jetzt, du bist gerade am Hauptbahnhof.
In 10 Minuten kommt hier die 3.
Und dann klickst du die an, diese Verbindung
und der sagt dir, diese Bahn ist übrigens jetzt gerade
dort. Ah, cool.
Weil das die TVB-API hergibt.
Gibt es das auch für mein Betriebssystem?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Aber jetzt habe ich seinen Namen leider vergessen.
Philipp Mattes heißt der, genau.
Der hatte die selbst geschrieben.
Schönen Gruß an Philipp Mattes.
Ist das ein Dresdner?
Ja.
Cool.
Es gibt so viele
coole Entwickler in Dresden,
die alle so viel cooles Zeugs machen.
Die trifft man dann aber
nur auf den CocoHeads-Treffen, oder wie?
Das sind leider auch nicht alle.
Also von den iOS-Infektoren.
Leute, geh zu den CocoHeads-Treffen.
Ich treffe auch immer wieder mal Leute,
die einfach das Konzept Meetup noch nie gehört haben.
Das finde ich sehr krass.
Ich habe auch ein Jahr lang ein Meetup organisiert,
bevor ich wüsste, wie so ein Meetup überhaupt abzulaufen ist.
Das muss ja nicht heißen.
Aber ich finde es cool, das Konzept Meetup
gefällt mir sehr, auch nach Jahren immer noch.
Und ich lerne da vieles.
lernt viele coole Leute kennen. Was zum Beispiel
immer spannend wäre, wäre ein Dresdner Podcaster
Meetup. Das läuft
seit heute jetzt bei Hendrik daheim.
Pass ja auf, jetzt kommen
die Leute gleich durch die Tür. Ich habe so mal
eine Zeit lang öffentliche
Gottesdienste in meiner Wohnung gehalten.
Ich als pastafarischer Fahrer,
ich habe halt Nudeln gekocht und habe das auf Twitter
angekündigt, dass ich hier jetzt Nudeln koche.
Und ich meine, es passiert ja vielen
Kirchen, dass die hier Gottesdienst feiern und es kommt
niemand. So war es bei mir halt auch immer.
Ja, so war es bei jedem meiner Gottesdienste.
Aber ich musste das machen, damit ich der
GIZ glaubhaft
schildern könnte, dass ich meine Wohnung
zur Glaubensstätte erklärt habe
und somit von laut Paragraph so und so
des Rundfunkstaatsvertrages von der GIZ-Gebühr befreit bin.
Nicht großartig. Hat es geklappt eigentlich?
Nee, die haben mir damals geschrieben, dass ich das gerne
annehme, meine Wohnung sei damit befreit,
aber laut Paragraph so und so anderes
Gesetz darf man in religiösen Glaubensstätten
nicht wohnen und bis ich ihnen nachweise, wo
ich wohne, muss ich stellvertretend für meine Glaubensstätte
zahlen. Also sie haben Humor bewiesen,
Aber mein Plan hat leider nicht geklappt.
Ich habe gerade
Richard Dawkins gelesen.
Sagt ihr den damals?
Ja, klar.
The God Delusion.
Sehr gutes Buch, auf jeden Fall.
Ich muss ehrlich sein, ich habe es nicht gelesen.
Ich habe gerade Richard Dawkins gelesen.
Das Buch.
Ich habe es gehört.
Das finde ich zählt auch.
Der hat ja einen britischen Dialekt.
Er hat selber gelesen.
Das steht in dem Buch.
der ist ja mit Douglas Adams befreundet gewesen.
Wenn du darüber nachdenkst,
es hörte sich auch immer so ein bisschen,
er hatte den Humor wie Douglas Adams.
Also ich kann nur empfehlen,
zieht euch mal The God Delusion von Richard Dawkins rein.
Ich höre es mir gerade einfach noch ein zweites Mal an,
weil ich es auch gut finde.
Und er hat an einer Stelle erwähnt,
dass es im britischen Recht
steuerliche Ausnahmen
für Glaubensgemeinschaften gibt.
Aber das ist halt diskriminiert,
weil es nur für monotheistische...
Was? Das hast du festgesetzt?
Glaubensrichtung, ja, ich meine, selbst wenn
heute ankommen, wird das nicht, diese
Kirchensteuergeschichte, das ist ja eigentlich absolut absurd,
aber wir nehmen es irgendwie,
viele Leute nehmen es ernst, weil es einfach schon immer
so war, aber wenn jetzt einer ankommt und sagt,
ich habe jetzt gerade eine neue Religionsgemeinschaft gegründet,
wir sind auch bereits, ich habe auch
bereits 100 Gläubige, ich möchte bitte,
dass ihr für mich Steuern eintreibt.
Genau, das hat John Oliver doch auch gemacht.
Ja, der hat aber nicht angefangen, Steuern
für sich eintreiben zu lassen, der hat einfach gesagt,
in den USA ist es so, dass du als Glaubensgemeinschaft
steuerfrei Spenden einsammeln kannst.
Ah, okay. Und er hat eine Glaubensgemeinschaft
gegründet, um Spenden einzuhalten.
Ja, wo Leute ihre Geldsamen hinschicken sollten
und Leute halt unter anderem ihre Sperma hingeschickt haben.
Achso,
weil man Geld sehen muss.
Plant a seed with your... Ja, genau.
Das war weird.
Ja.
Ich bin sehr froh, Pastafahrer zu sein.
Bist du immer noch? Ich dachte, du wärst irgendwann ausgetreten.
Nee, ich bin aus der Piratenpartei ausgetreten,
aber nicht nur beim Glaubentum hier.
Wieso bist du aus der Piratenpartei ausgetreten?
Ja, weil es vorbei war.
Ist vorbei.
Die standen neulich noch auf der Ballzeit.
Aber wann bin ich ausgetreten? 2014?
Was wählt man denn stattdessen?
Gibt es irgendwie eine coole neue...
Ja, Partei natürlich.
Die Partei.
Ich kenne Leute, die in der Partei sind.
Ich kenne auch Leute, die die Partei gewählt haben.
Ich habe auch schon die Partei gewählt.
Aha.
Ich behalte meine Meinung jetzt für mich.
Die Partei hat eine schöne Aktion jetzt vor kurzem gehabt.
Beziehungsweise läuft, glaube ich, immer noch.
Du kannst aktuell für Thüringen Bier spenden.
Wieso für Thüringen?
weil es ein tristes Bundesland ist und wir es brauchen.
Aber die haben bald Landtagswahl
und die Partei sammelt Bierspenden.
Sagen wir so aus Sachsen.
Aber es gibt ja wirklich
so einen Glücksindex,
gab es mal, glaube ich, in Deutschland, wo die Leute
befragt haben, wie glücklich sie sind. Und Thüringen ist halt mit
ein bisschen Abstand das tristeste Bundesland der
Europäische. Echt? Ja. Also das wundert mich nicht.
Ich habe schon mal in Thüringen gewohnt. Das passt
perfekt ins Bild.
Jedenfalls kannst du aktuell bei der
Partei Geld spenden. Aus
diesem Geld machen sie durch Alchemie Bier.
Also kauft Bier.
Sehr gut, finde ich gut.
Dann nach der Landtagswahl gehen sie in kleine Orte in Thüringen,
für die gespendet wurden.
Also sie darf spenden für jeden Ort, der weniger als 1000 Einwohner hat.
Und jeder dieser Orte, der weniger als 5% AfD-Wähler hat,
kriegt von der Partei Bier.
Schwierig.
Finde ich wunderschön.
Und finde ich auch schön, dass bisher, ich glaube,
wenn ich mich alles täusche, müsste ich die Webseite nochmal aufmachen.
Also bei der letzten 5% weniger als 5% hatte oder bei der nächsten?
Bei der nächsten, die ist jetzt bald.
die Landtagswahl in Thüringen. Ist es Landtagswahl?
Ich glaube, es ist Landtag. Jedenfalls
hier Bierspende für Thüringen.
Orte, die
sind mittlerweile mehr Orte, aber
die ersten Spender waren alle
für Bornhagen. Die sind auch noch
immerhin 200 Liter für Bornhagen
hier gespendet. Spenden unter anderem von
Ex-Gildo, Bernd Höcke und Ralf Strunski.
Ihr seid toll.
Vor allem Bernd Höcke.
Ich weiß, das ist unter anderem
mein Dad halt unter einem
Pseudonym für Bornhagen Bier gespendet.
Echt?
Aber nicht als Bernd Höcke, oder?
Das möchte ich nicht.
I can either confirm or deny.
Aber die werden das Bier leider nicht bekommen.
Ich wette mal nicht, dass Bornhagen
unter 5% darf.
Bernd Höcke selber ist bereits 5% der Bevölkerung
von Bornhagen.
Weißt du, wir haben so wenige Leute.
Aber ich finde es schön, hier sind mittlerweile
wirklich echt viele Ortschaften auf der Liste,
die Bier bekommen haben.
Aber sie dürfen nur maximal 1.000 Einwohner haben
oder unter 1.000 Einwohner haben.
Hier steht, aber nur an Dörfer unter 1000 Einwohner, an denen die verfickte AfD bei der Landtagswahl am 27.10. weniger als 5% der Stimme erhält.
Ich lese hier im Wortlaut.
Ich finde das immer witzig, wenn Leute auf Twitter die AfD referenzieren mit dem Hashtag Fuck AfD und dann die Fuck AfD schreiben.
Oder ne, No AfD. No AfD oder Fuck AfD? Eins von beiden.
Meinst du nur die AfD oder die Fick?
Was?
Irritiert.
Ich habe nicht ganz verstanden, was du meinst.
Ah ja,
Twitter halt.
Nee, ich finde viele Bierspenden hier.
Finde ich großartig. Wir haben auch noch ein anderes Projekt am Laufen,
dass du bei der Partei, es war glaube ich noch
neu in ihrem Blog, du kannst
ähm
du kannst der Partei Geld
spenden und zwar
für
äh
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Genau, du kannst bei der Partei jetzt auch Geld spenden
für den kurdischen Roten Halbmond.
Und das Schöne ist,
dass wenn du das der Partei spendest
und die das für dich weiterspenden,
weil ja Parteienfinanzierung in Deutschland gedeckelt ist,
dass du somit auch Geld aus der Kasse nimmst,
die CDU und SPD bekommen hätten.
Und somit für jeden Euro hier rechnerisch,
den sie an die Partei spenden,
unterstützt die CDU den kurdischen Roten Halbmond
mit 30 Cent die SPD ebenfalls.
Die Grünen spendieren 10 Cent, die Liberalen
in Anführungsstrichen 8 Cent,
Seehofers irre regionale Splitterpartei
und die Linke je 7 Cent und auch die verfickte
AfD gibt ihren Senf dazu, 5 Cent.
Seehofers irre regionale
Splitterpartei.
Aber das finde ich großartig.
Du spendest der Partei Geld und alle anderen spenden
quasi mit. Ja, rechnerisch gesehen.
Finde ich toll.
Das nenne ich Hack the System.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Hack the Planet.
Auf jeden Fall.
So viel zur Partei.
Hast du noch einen GitHub-Star?
Ja, und zwar habe ich...
Oder bin ich jetzt dran?
Nee, du bist jetzt mal dran, stimmt.
Ich bin dran.
Scheiße.
Nicht mal live vorbereiten können wir.
Doch, ich habe was Schönes gefunden, und zwar XKCDFS.
Uh, das klingt spannend.
Da haben wir jetzt so ein Ding.
Das ist einfach, das ist eine Anwendung, die startest du,
dann gibst du dir einen Pfad und dann ist da plötzlich ein Ordner mit XKCDs.
gemountet. Ah, ist das so ein Fuse-Internet-Volume-Dings da?
Genau, es ist ein Fuse, um Sachen zu lesen.
Das hast du mir, glaube ich, vor Jahren schon mal gezeigt,
sowas ähnliches, dass du halt wirklich einfach
irgendwelche Webseiten quasi als Dateisystem
mountest. Das war eine super witzige Idee
auf jeden Fall. Das ist super gut, also
dieses gesamte Fuse-Konzept finde ich auch super schön,
weil es halt einfach auch das Kopieren und hin- und herschieben
und bearbeiten von Sachen sehr
angenehm macht. Also ich kenne mich jetzt nicht
wirklich aus, was genau das tut, aber...
Es gibt ja, das hat jetzt nichts mit Fuse zu tun,
es gibt ja für VS Code seit einiger
Zeit ein SSH-Plugin
und das funktioniert ausgezeichnet.
Okay, da musst du mir gleich weiter dem unten.
Machst du VS Code auf
und sagst hier, mach mal eine SSH-Verbindung
zu der Kiste da drüben auf. Da muss
nicht mal VS Code selber laufen.
Also es muss ja nicht drauf sein, du musst dich bloß per SSH
drauf anmelden können. Und dann kannst du
da drin einen Ordner öffnen und dann ist deine...
Oh, schick.
...hast du das in VS Code offen, als ob du es einfach
bei dir offen hättest. Und wenn du die Konsole unten
aufmachst, bist du einfach per SSH dort drin
mit einer Schelle. Nice, fixing bugs on prod like a pro.
Ja, exakt.
Also wenn ich das
zu meinen PHP-Tagen
schon gehabt hätte, dann hätte ich
hier FDP nicht so
missbrauchen müssen.
Apropos Fixing Bugs on Prod like a Pro,
hast du diesen Boeing-Tweet vor kurzem mitbekommen?
Nein.
Bei Boeing war es mal so, dass die
Software testen wollten und die haben einfach
alle Heads of Software Engineering auf einen
Testflug mit der neuen Software im System
gesetzt.
And during the test flight, the plane
started shaking and the software
engineers were able to implement a mid-flight
fix via the turbulence control software.
Ich möchte bitte nicht für Boeing arbeiten.
I have yet to find a better example of an organization
putting software leaders' skin in the game
of a high-stakes product development.
Was zum Teufel?
You think you test in prod,
but do you test in prod like Boeing used to?
Das ist richtig hardcore.
Deswegen hat alles bloß eine
Telnet-Stelle bei denen, oder wie?
Das ist richtig, richtig hart.
Überleg mal, dass du in einem Flieger sitzt
und live die Software von dem Flieger updatest.
Vor allem, du müsstest ja dann irgendwie Komponenten
von dem Flugzeug mittendrin rebooten, oder?
Wahrscheinlich.
Oder ist das alles irgendwie in JavaScript geschrieben
und die hängen sich da mit dem Chrome als...
Um Gottes Willen.
Stell dir mal vor,
JavaScript ist gone to far.
Ach du Scheiße.
Aber ich meine, wenn das Flugzeug wackelt
und du das per Software fixst...
Wenn die irgendwelche Turbulence-Control-Software hat,
also dementsprechend, wenn die wahrscheinlich übersteuert...
Wahrscheinlich haben sie einfach einen Bug gefixt,
dass die nicht angegangen ist.
Das machen ja auch irgendwie so die DVB-Straßenbahnen.
Ich habe auf Twitter nachgefragt,
warum die manchmal so cool shaken an der Haltestelle.
Und das ist, weil die Software haben zum Ausgleichen von...
So wie du manchmal dein Handy schütteln musst,
damit sich dein Kompass wieder arretiert.
Nicht ganz das Gleiche,
aber wenn diese Software halt überkompensiert,
dann fangen diese Bahnen an zu wackeln,
so ein schönes, rhythmisches...
So Lowrider-mäßig.
Hin und her.
Lowrider Straßenbahn.
Falls ihr es noch nicht gemerkt habt,
unsere letzten Folgen hatten in den Shownotes
immer noch alternative Titelvorschläge,
die Hendrik somit
gegeben hat. Ich suche mir davon immer
einen aus, den wir dann tatsächlich nutzen.
Ja, unser Ablauf ist immer, ich schneide die Folge
und ich mache Vorschläge und die Shownotes
machst du dann glücklicherweise zu Ende.
Genau, und lad das dann hoch.
Und Hendrik hat meistens
ein paar sehr amüsante Titelvorschläge,
müsst ihr mal in die Shownotes reinschauen,
verpasst ihr vielleicht noch einen Witz.
Also nicht so schlimm, wenn ihr einen Witz verpasst, aber...
Weil unsere Folgen ja sonst immer so langweilig sind.
Genau, also das war gerade XKCDFS.
Und ja, ansonsten passieren irgendwie noch so Sachen.
Ich hab mal rumgespielt zum ersten Mal überhaupt
mit so Code-Coverage-Tools.
Okay.
Da gibt's irgendwie so K-Coff und C-Coff
und GR-Coff.
Und Koff-Fefe und...
Vielleicht kommt das da her.
Fefe-Coverage.
Wie doller du von
Fefe abgedeckt wirst und schon noch
und die...
Nee, Code Coverage ist wirklich
Kofffefe.
Fefe-Koff.
Ich mag ja Teapot-OS sehr.
Also zumindest sind das Tools,
die einfach
deiner Anwendung, deiner gebauten Binary,
das funktioniert bei
C++, C Rust,
zuschauen. Zum Beispiel, wenn du
eine Test-Binary ausführst
und dann Coverage-Daten darüber
sammeln, wie viele Codepfade
du von deiner Library tatsächlich betreten hast
und damit testest du Test-Coverage von
deiner Library für Zipplitz. Ich habe mich immer gefragt
oder für, sagen wir,
nativ kompilierte
Libraries. Ich habe mich immer gefragt, wie das
funktioniert und das ist
eigentlich ein ziemlich cooles Ding. Es funktioniert halt
auf Debug-Builds.
Du musst dir
debugt quasi live einfach deine
Anwendung. Es ist nicht ganz so einfach, aber ich kann
es auch nicht ohne Probe schreiben.
Und das gibt es für Rust auf jeden Fall auch.
Und das geht garantiert auch für Swift genauso.
Okay.
Das ist ziemlich nice.
Und da gibt es für Cargo,
gibt es einfach Cargo K-Kauf
oder noch eine andere GR-Kauf von Mozilla.
Da gibt es mehrere Alternativen.
Oder einfach sagen kannst, führ mal diesen Test aus.
Und da fällt dann einfach zum Schluss,
ich weiß, vielleicht kennen das viele schon,
aber fällt dann einfach so eine HTML-Datei raus
mit deinem Code und welche Codezeilen
wie häufig betreten wurden.
Ich meine, Code Coverage ist natürlich eine schwierige Metrik,
weil viele Leute das überschätzen, was das aussagt.
Code Coverage ist natürlich nicht Branch Coverage.
Branch Coverage ist nochmal was anderes.
Und dann heißt es natürlich noch nicht, dass alle Edge Cases
deiner Scouts... Aber es ist ein guter Anfang,
um zu wissen, wenn dieser Code nie getestet wird,
wenn mein Case nie ausgeführt wurde,
dann sagt das natürlich immer...
Es ist hinreichend,
aber nicht...
Es ist notwendig, aber nicht hinreichend.
Ja, so kann man es, glaube ich, sagen.
Das funktioniert ja ganz gut,
auf jeden Fall. Und das sind die klassischen Sachen.
Also ich bin am Anfang, als ich mit diesem Rust Meetup
angefangen habe, habe ich dir mal gefragt, kann man denn das
überhaupt debuggen? Die Leute denken immer
solche grundlegenden Sachen wie
Debugger-Attention
oder Backtrace rauskriegen oder jetzt hier
Code-Cavage. Das funktioniert natürlich nur bei
C und C++. Ist nicht so.
Mit dem GDB kannst du auch
Rust-Binary-Debuggen. Du kannst dir auch da die Symbole anzeigen.
Das hat das erst ein bisschen später
gelernt, weil natürlich das ganze Zeug ist
jahrelang für
C allein gebaut wurde,
weil es gab halt keine andere native
Sprache wirklich, die Leute verwendet haben.
Aber das ist jetzt alles da.
Cool. Ziemlich nice.
Und eine andere Sache, die ich noch gefunden habe,
die ziemlich cool ist, es gibt ja für
Rust-Proc-Makros.
Das heißt, ich kann irgendwie meinen Code annotieren.
Der
wird dann irgendwie verändert. Ein klassisches
Beispiel ist Serde. Ich schreibe daran,
dieser Struct ist serialisierbar,
deserialisierbar.
Erwähne ich einfach oben in so einem Attribut
ein bestimmtes Borg-Makro und das kriegt dann
meinen Code zu fressen und variiert anderen Code.
Das sind einfach bloß Rust-Funktionen,
die ein Token-Tree
von meinem, was weiß ich, von meinem
Stück Codeblock oder Struct oder so reinkriegen
und dann einen anderen Token-Tree
ausspucken, der noch daneben mit
reinkompiliert wird.
Und die haben immer
die
verwenden eine Library, die heißt
Syn und Quote. Die eine
ist ein Rust-Parser, weil du es
als String kriegst. Du kriegst
tatsächlich den annotierten Rust-Code als String rein.
Und das andere
ist ein Rust-Serializer.
Das ist ein Makro,
wo du einfach Rust schreibst und dann kannst du
mit so Platzhaltern
deine eigentlichen Sachen reinschreiben.
Das ist eigentlich ganz angenehm. Aber du musst es halt
immer, du musst diese Brock-Makros immer
mitbauen. Das heißt, wenn ich
eine Library ausliefere, die
zum Beispiel Serde verwendet,
oder irgendwas, was Brock-Makros verwendet,
kompiliere ich immer auch Quote und
SYN mit. Das heißt den
Rust-Parser,
der dann
bei meinem Komplieren verwendet wird.
Und dafür gibt es jetzt eine schöne Alternative.
Und zwar heißt die
What. Guter Name.
Natürlich. Und die ist von dem
David Tolnoy,
der selber auch
Serde baut. Und was das macht, ist,
du hast einfach diese Funktion, die dein Rust-Code
reinkriegt, mit
diesen beiden Dependencies,
hast du einfach vorkompiliert
zu WebAssembly
und dann ist dein
Proc-Makro, das schreibst du halt hin,
das sieht dann auch immer gleich aus,
das ist einfach eine Funktion mit dem
Public Member Makro
und dann oben drüber hast du noch stehen
Include Bytes, so ein Include Makro
für Rust und da inkludest du dann
dieses Stück bereits vorkompiliertes
WebAssembly. Das heißt, du kannst
es kompiliert ausliefern
und es wird dann einfach das
WebAssembly in deinem
Build-Prozess ausgeführt
und das Ding hat einen eigenen WebAssembly-Interpreter
mit eingebaut.
Ich verstehe den Namen
jetzt.
Was?
Das macht Build-Time
ein ganzes Stück schneller, weil
ein paar von den Dependencies, also eigentlich
allgemein, das hatte ich ja schon für Node
oder so empfohlen, aber tatsächlich so Build-Time
Dependencies auch nochmal kompilieren zu müssen,
das musst du dann halt einfach nicht mehr machen.
Gerade wenn die systemunabhängig sind.
Wenn sie einfach bloß ein Stück Code lesen
Code ausspucken müssen, wenn es irgendwas ist, was du einfach
so als Blackbox-Funktion verwenden kannst.
Da bitte.
Ist was dran?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Witzig.
Du hast hier noch ein weiteres
Ding auf die Liste geschrieben. Rust-Bitcode
beziehungsweise darunter Swift-Bindgen.
Fragezeichen,
Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen.
Habe ich mir beide gar nicht so genau angeguckt. Wollte ich mal mit dir
drüber reden. Also es gibt irgendwie Swift-Bindgen,
habe ich schon wieder vergessen. Aber das ist einfach
was, ja, Rust-Swift um irgendwie
für
Rust und Swift so
Codeübergänge gut hinzukriegen.
Und Rust Bitcode habe ich tatsächlich vergessen.
Das war denn das nochmal?
Swift-Bindgen und das ist hier
Rust Bitcode.
Rust-Toolchain für
achso, für Xcode
compatible iOS Bitcode.
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Ich habe vergessen, genau.
iOS, und das kannst du jetzt wahrscheinlich besser erklären,
geht irgendwie
dazu über, dass man nicht mehr
komplett kompiliert, sondern
dass man irgendwie so eine Art
halb zu Ende kompilierten Bitcode ausführt.
Die Idee ist, dass du
in den App-Store nicht
komplett wirklich eine fertige Binary legst,
sondern, das ist jetzt
nicht ganz richtig, aber so geht es um die
Richtung von diesem LVMIR,
was ja auch wie so ein Zwischenschritt ist,
dass du halt so ein leicht abstrakteres
nämlich das Wort selber
in den Mund, Kompilat hast.
Wir haben einen
Post, meine Damen und Herren.
Dass Apple halt theoretisch weiter optimizieren kann
für zukünftige Plattformen.
Beziehungsweise, ich glaube,
der Präsidentfall dafür war die aktuelle
Generation der Apple Watch.
Die haben eine leicht andere Architektur darauf
und haben die Watch-Apps quasi im Store
nochmal umbauen können,
damit die effizienter auf der Plattform laufen.
Was natürlich auch sinnvoll ist, weil wenn jetzt eine neue Plattform
dazu ist, dazu kommt mit einer anderen Architektur,
muss nicht, und das ist ein Vorteil,
den Android gegenüber
iOS hat wahrscheinlich,
wenn du jetzt eine neue Architektur hinzufügst oder sowas,
dann müssten alle Leute, die ihre
App bereits gepublisht haben, die nicht nochmal
neu bauen, damit sie dann auch auf der Architektur läuft.
Genau, also zumindest
Apple geht da jetzt nicht so weit,
dass sie die Architektur komplett über den Haufen werfen und
nur Apps laufen, die neu gebaut werden, zumindest
nicht in letzter Zeit.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das damals war
mit Umsprung auf den beiden alten
Geräten, aber
da war ich noch nicht in der Bubble
drin, da kann ich nicht viel zu sagen.
Jedenfalls ist es so, dass du
halt dann die aktuellen Optimizations
du es nicht mit drin hast, wenn du es nicht neu bauen würdest. Mit Bitcode kannst du das eben schon machen.
Und das ist im Prinzip ein cooles Konzept.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was der aktuelle Status quo ist. Man setzt einfach nur einen Haken
mit Xcode, von wegen, mach das mal. Und Xcode lädt dann den Bitcode einfach hoch.
Das war immer noch so ein Problem mit gewissen Dependencies.
Das hast du auch bei Android gesehen, als die auf
ihre neue Runtime umgestiegen sind, dass du dann Apps runtergeladen hast
und dann auch noch einmal so ein Dialog nach dem Installieren durchlief mit
ihre App wird für ihr lokales System optimiert.
Sag mal, das Gerät baut die selber neu?
Naja, es hat das irgendwie
den Java-Byte-Code nochmal
nachoptimiert oder sowas. Fancy.
Ja, ich meine, das ist natürlich,
bei Android ist das vielleicht, weil du 35.000
unterschiedliche Gerätetypen hast. Bei iOS
musst du das wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Du kannst es dann direkt für deine korrekte Architektur
aus dem Playstore runterladen, aber das kann dann halt
Apple wahrscheinlich besser für dich machen
als der Entwickler.
Machen die das dann auch quasi?
Soweit ich falle, macht das Apple-Server-seitig.
Also den Bitcode lädst du
als App oder als Customer
selber gar nicht mehr runter.
Soweit ich weiß, lädst du
die fertige App immer runter.
Und die ist halt möglicherweise eine von Apple
nachoptimierte Variante dessen, was der Developer
hochgeladen hat.
Das ist schon irgendwie geil.
Zumindest, ich war
in Schweden.
Okay, Thema.
Hallo Sascha.
Sascha hat mir auch Urlaubstipps gegeben,
was man sich in Schweden angucken kann.
Wie lange wir uns schon nicht mehr gesehen haben.
Ich war in Schweden im Urlaub
so anderthalb Wochen, also die Hälfte der Zeit
war ich in Dänemark.
Und ich habe da einen Bekannten
getroffen, den Linus von
Mulvart.
Und da hatte ich auch das Thema irgendwie,
weil Mulvart irgendwie die Desktop-Clients
sind in Rust gebaut.
Auch das ganze VB1-Zeugs, was wir da drin machen.
Und Netzwerk-Zeugs.
Und der hat mir gemeint, ja, aber für
iOS, dann bauen wir jetzt noch wieder Zeugs in C++,
weil die Toolchain
es nicht hergibt, dass du das
in diesen Bitcode kompilierst.
Ah, so kommt der Umschwenk jetzt her.
Genau, und deswegen habe ich da mal geschaut,
aber das gibt es doch bestimmt schon.
Jetzt haben wir den Bogen geschlossen zu
Rust Bitcode, was auch immer das war.
Das wusste ich vorher auch nicht mehr.
Das ist einfach eine Toolchain.
Die hat immerhin schon
200 Stars.
Und es war vor einem Monat das letzte Mal
angefasst worden.
Es ist eine...
Sternanteil ist ja immer ein guter Qualitätsindex.
Ja, nicht unbedingt.
Es ist ein Index dafür,
wie lively das Projekt ist. Vielleicht gibt es auch schon
irgendwie einen anderen Fork oder vielleicht gibt es auch
einfach irgendwann als Target
in dem Rust-Compiler selber, damit du das
als Target angeben kannst.
Das wäre prinzipiell...
Ist ja jetzt nicht schwierig,
der Clang und Swift-Compiler sind
LLVM-Compiler, Rust ist ein LLVM-Compiler.
Du musst einfach bloß das richtige Backend
anschließen und wahrscheinlich 35.000
Konfigurationen machen, die ich jetzt nicht überblicke.
Und hier hast du einfach eine Konfiguration,
mit der du Rust nach
iOS-Bitcode
oder Xcode-kompatiblen
iOS-Bitcode kombinieren kannst.
Was eigentlich ziemlich nice ist. Und wenn du das kombinierst mit
sowas wie
SwiftBindGen, kannst du jetzt hier
Rust-Code so schreiben,
dass man den von Swift aus
verwenden kann.
Switching the Gap between Swift and Rust.
Das gefällt mir sehr. Also der Titel davon.
Passend zu dem Tweet, den du mir heute weitergeleitet hast.
Ah ja, das...
Das war kein Schwein, das war, ich glaube eine Möwe.
Ja, das war eigentlich, hast du mal hochgesculpt da drin,
das war eigentlich so eine Folge, das war erst die
Möwe packt so eine kleine Krabbe
aus dem Wasser und dann siehst du, wie sie die Krabbe im Maul hat
und dann lässt sie die aber wieder fallen
und dann greift die Krabbe einfach der
Möwe so irgendwo ins Gefieder
und hängt sie da so fest.
Das letzte Bild war, wenn die Möwe
total bedeppert guckt, weil sie eine Krabbe da irgendwo hängt.
Sinnbild für Rust, wirft Interob.
Fand ich sehr schön.
Kommt auch in die Show Notes.
Ja, ich möchte das nochmal raussuchen.
Python 3.8
ist rausgekommen. Ja, aber
irgendwie hat es nicht so viel mit drin.
Es ist ja nicht schlecht, dass es nicht viel mit drin hat, aber
was ich gesehen hatte, war der
Walrus-Operator, der neue.
Walrus-Operator? Der Doppelpunkt ist gleich.
Ein bisschen aus wie James
von Miss Busters. Das finde ich super hässlich.
Was macht das?
Soweit ich es verstanden habe, ist es so ein bisschen so ein
if-let-unwrap von wie Swift das hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir das bei...
Also quasi, du geholst den Wert
und, also zum Beispiel if, Wert,
Walrus, wo immer der Wert herkommt,
macht dasselbe wie
du ziehst den Wert in eine Variable und machst
einen Check-up if-wert-not-non.
Also
ich sehe den Wert davon
jetzt noch nicht ganz. Es ist ein bisschen
ein syntaktischer Angleich an das, was andere moderne
Sprachen machen, aber das ist halt
du sparst dir gefühlt nicht so viel.
Ich habe es noch nicht ganz verstanden.
Aber
es ist etwas.
It's something.
An dieser Stelle füge ich dann noch in die
Show Notes ein, einen Rant, den ich
ziemlich gut zu lesen fand.
Ich meine, Rants lesen sich immer ganz nett.
Python is not a great programming language.
Oh, wer hat das denn gesagt?
Das steht hier so.
Let me start by saying nice things
about Python. Die Philosophie sagt,
Es gibt nur einen korrekten Weg, Sachen zu machen.
Es ist einfach zu lernen am Anfang.
Es gibt eine ziemlich umfangreiche Standardbibliothek.
Es gibt ein großes Ökosystem für Third-Party-Apps.
Die Forced Identification ist zwar,
da kann man sehen, wie man will,
aber sieht erstmal lesbar aus einigermaßen.
Das Import-System macht,
the Import-System makes it easy to trace file paths for any dependency.
Keine Ahnung.
Und das Letzte ist, was gut ist, ist Doc Strings.
und dann kommt nochmal doppelt so viel
Sachen, die er negativ findet, irgendwie
Classical Inheritance ist halt so ein Ding, dann hast du
irgendwie Half of each Django App
starts with
Super, Klammer auf, Klammer zu
Punkt, Unterstrich, Unterstrich, Init
Unterstrich, Unterstrich, in Klammern
Sternchen Arcs, Komma, Sternchen
Sternchen, KW Arcs, also Quarks
das ist einfach alles. Uh, Quarks habe ich noch nie
genannt. Quarks, das heißt
fast überall Quarks. Ja, ich habe das immer
Kaviars genannt im Kopf.
Und es ist Quarks.
Quarks.
Ja, aber das ist ja wahr.
Okay, das passiert wirklich häufig in Python, aber...
All the goofy String Literals.
Es gibt U-Strings und R-Strings
und F-Strings.
Ach ja, Python hat halt auch seinen fairen Anteil
Kraft da mit drin.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Naja, ich finde es trotzdem...
Top-Level-List und Top-Level-Map
und Comprehensions allgemein.
Comprehensions sind kein schlechtes Feature.
in Python. Das geht halt nicht sauber in Python.
Die Tatsache, dass man ein
Seven-Character-Lambda-Keyword
hat, was man
meistens nicht benutzt. Ja, vor allem, weil es ausschließlich
One-Liner zulässt. Also Lambda-Send-Python-Boken
generell diese Functional Paradigms,
diese Klassiker wie Map und
ja, Filter, Reduce, weiß ich gar nicht,
was Python nennt, wahrscheinlich auch wieder anders
wie alle anderen Sprachen. Das ist halt nicht
schön in Python. Das wollen die
klassischen Python-Listers
das nicht und deswegen klappt es auch nicht so schick.
Aber die
wollen das, also du kannst es halt alles mit List Comprehensions
abbilden, aber ich finde das halt auch
nicht wirklich schön.
Ja, List Comprehensions sind genauso wie, wenn du
alles in, äh, das hatte ich
irgendwann noch nicht gesehen. Simple List Comprehensions sind ja noch
okay, die lassen sich ja auch lesen, aber es gibt ja Leute, die
schachteln List Comprehensions und es gibt Leute, die
machen da wirklich 20 Zeiler draus und so
holy fuck, das ganze, diese ganze, ganze
Blockcode hier, eine lange List Comprehension.
Dann gehst du einmal mit den Augen komplett rein bis zur Mitte
und dann liest du es rückwärts wieder, um zu verstehen, was nacheinander
dann gehst du hin und her, weil du nicht verstanden hast, weil
das viel zu viel Code ist in der Liscope-Rension.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Mehr Sprachen brauchen
den Pipeline-Operator.
Der Pipeline-Operator
ist jetzt der, du weißt, einfach so
ein Map, was so irgendwie Elixir oder?
Ja, genau. Okay.
Der das einfach durchpipet. Ja, nee, das wäre die
richtige Lesreihenfolge.
Ich weiß nicht, haben
Leute, die
Right-to-Left-Languages können, also als
Muttersprache, so Arabisch, Hebräisch oder sowas,
haben die, oder Urdu, haben die irgendwie
Vorteile gegenüber anderen,
solchen Codes zu lesen? Ich würde gerade sagen, naja, du musst ja
trotzdem
die Begriffe und die ganzen
einzelnen Phrases
da drinne dann wieder von links nach rechts
lesen. Sag mal, du sprichst nativ
Urdu und
du kannst dann, also
du hast gute Englischkenntnisse,
dass es kein Problem ist, Englisch zu lesen, kannst
du schneller solche
Ausdrücke parseln, die so geschafft sind?
Dein Gehirn wird auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
einen Vorteil haben,
regelmäßig die Lesrichtung zu ändern.
Stimmt, das musst du ja eh die ganze Zeit machen.
Weil du das übst, aber ansonsten,
eigentlich ist es, wenn du
ein Wort in deutscher Sprache,
in der normalen,
in arabisch, wollte ich schon sagen,
in lateinisch und zeichengeschriebenen Buchstaben liest,
ist es nicht so, dass du das Buchstabe für Buchstabe liest.
Also ist dir die Lesrichtung eigentlich egal.
Stimmt, du ergreifst die Worte als komplett paketig.
Du ergreifst es als Symbol quasi.
Dementsprechend hat zum Beispiel chinesisch
keinen großen Lesegeschwindigkeitsvorteil
gegenüber westlichen Sprachen.
Joa, hätte ich
jetzt auch nicht wirklich erwartet.
Jetzt vergleichbar eingestuft.
Also aber von links nach rechts
oder rechts nach links.
Ich freue mich zumindest, wenn das in JavaScript-Einzug erhält,
dass man hier so einen Dreiecksoperator schreiben kann.
Der sieht dann so aus, dass du ein Pipe
und ein größer Halszeichen hast.
Ja, genauso wie Elixir.
Da ist immer noch nicht raus, an welcher Stelle dann dort
ein Await reinkommt.
Aber wir machen
einen Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Demnächst kommt
TypeScript 3.7 raus
und die haben dann zwei neue
Operatoren. Also,
weil die einfach im JavaScript
bereits in dem Standardisierungsprozess
eine derartige Stabilität erreicht haben,
dass die TypeScript-Leute
sich bereits trauen, es in den Compiler einzubauen.
Dann kannst du in TypeScript, hast du dann den Elvis-Operator.
Der Elvis-Operator
war Doppelpunkt-Fragezeichen, oder?
Fragezeichen-Punkt.
Ah.
Nee, Fragezeichen-Doppelpunkt wäre der
richtige Elvis-Operator, so wie es sich
Hubblock definiert. Da sieht es ja am meisten aus wie Elvis.
Ja, es ist zumindest
ein Fragezeichenpunkt. Und was
ich am Anfang noch nicht ganz verstanden habe, ist, es gibt dann
Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen.
Und das ist nur Knowledge Coalescing,
heißt das. Und das ist ein Problem, was JavaScript hat.
JavaScript hat einfach viel zu viele Arten und Weisen,
nichts auszudrücken.
Wo wir
bereits wieder bei nichts wären.
Und zwar sind ja sehr viele Sachen
in JavaScript falsi.
Also null ist falsi.
Lehrer-String ist Falsy und Null ist Falsy
und
False ist Falsy und so weiter und so fort.
Und in JavaScript kannst du...
Ist nicht bei Definition False.
Ist das falseste Falsy unter den
Falsy-Werken? Ich weiß nicht, ob man die Falsiness
irgendwie von Sachen messen kann.
Ob man Sachen nach Falsiness sortiert.
Was ist mehr Falsy als was anderes?
Was ist manchmal
Truthy, aber nicht immer?
Müsste mal meinen Code
auf Arbeit lesen.
zumindest führt das zu Problemen.
Wir hatten zum Beispiel ein Beispiel.
Zum Beispiel ein Beispiel.
Gehst du manchmal so in deine Sprache
und reflektierst, was man eigentlich
den ganzen Tag manchmal so fühlt?
Darf ich dir ganz kurz eine Frage zwischenwerfen?
Kann man eigene Types falsy oder truthy machen
in JavaScript?
Boah, vielleicht.
Ich habe es nie probiert,
aber eigentlich nicht.
Also was im Endeffekt passieren wird,
wenn du was ausdrückst,
Du könntest die
toString-Methode überschreiben,
dass die einen leeren String
auf jeden Fall bei deinem Projekt zurückgibt.
Dann würde es eventuell
bei einem Doppel-Istgleich-Vergleich
Oh Gott, dann macht das automatisch
Strings draus?
Bei JavaScript gibt es ja
das istgleich-istgleich und das istgleich-istgleich-istgleich.
Das alte
istgleich-istgleich hat eine komische Semantik, wo dann
plötzlich rauskommt. Ach, das hat die komische
Semantik. Das ist das alte. Genau.
Deswegen haben sie eines mit noch mehr istgleichs hinzugefügt.
Das hat keine komische Semantik. Das ist genauso komisch.
Das ist anders komisch.
Ja, aber es macht nicht, dass du sagen kannst,
der Charakter
2 ist identisch zu der
Zahl 2. Nee, okay, es castet nicht automatisch
die Typen zusammen. Und was das macht, ist, dass es
Sachen vergleicht, nachdem es
zu einem String gecastet hat.
Funktioniert das generell? Ich glaube, das ist die Art
und Weise, wie das das handhabt.
Das ist bei vielen
anderen Script-Sprachen auch so.
Das ist bei PHP, glaube ich, ähnlich.
Das waren einfach so die Zeiten
in den 90ern, als man sich dachte,
wäre es nicht praktisch, wenn man einfach alles als String ausdrücken könnte.
Anyway, also ich glaube, vielleicht könnte man
das probieren. Es gibt eine Funktion,
eine Top-Level-Funktion boolean,
wo du irgendwas reinschmeißt und das sagt dir dann, ob das
true oder false ist. Vielleicht
kann man dafür irgendwas beschreiben, weiß ich nicht.
Aber... Sorry für den Derailed hier.
Derailed, also
falsiness oder truthiness in JavaScript,
es ist eine
Leidensgeschichte.
Und was
was Leute in JavaScript trotzdem immer mal wieder
machen, ist, dass sie irgendwie schreiben, A ist
gleich B oder C.
Und wenn dann
das B nicht da ist,
undefined ist oder null ist,
dann ist es halt C.
Also dein Default-Wert.
Okay, ja. A ist gleich B oder C.
Das hat allerdings das Problem, wenn du...
Aber das kann ja nur aufgrund des Konzepts der
Truthy und Forciness... Genau. Das geht jetzt auf
Truthy und Forciness. Du hast einfach eine ganz normale
Oder-Operation und es geht auch mit einer
Operation, das gibt es auch in anderen Sprachen,
das Ergebnis von einer Oder-Operation in
JavaScript ist einfach das erste, was True
ist. Okay.
Und das ist dann selber Truthy, immer noch,
ja, und dementsprechend kannst du das in einem
If verwenden. Witzig,
okay, ja. Ja.
Das hat das Problem, wenn du damit
mit Sachen arbeitest, die
an sich auch Truthy oder Falsy sein könnten,
zum Beispiel Zahlen oder
Strings. Wir hatten einen Bug, wo plötzlich
irgendwie bestimmte Werte in einem Dashboard bei uns
runtergegangen sind, weil jemand irgendwie gesagt hat,
naja, wir ziehen das hier gerade nach TypeScript um.
Da sagt mir der Compiler, das könnte
undefined sein.
Dann machen wir da jetzt mal
ein oder
oder null
draus oder null draus oder sowas.
Und dann gab es halt Situationen, wo dann der
vordere Wert vor dem oder eine null war.
Und wir das
dann den gesamten Wert
verworfen haben, obwohl er einfach bloß null war.
Und das war dann, glaube ich, ein Fehler.
Das war dann ein Error-Count,
der bei Null komplett verworfen wurde.
Das war aber geil.
Dann sind irgendwelche Metriken runtergegangen.
Das ist scheiße.
Und was jetzt neu ist in TypeScript 3.7
und dann irgendwann hoffentlich auch
in einem JavaScript-Interpreter in ihrer Nähe,
ist, dass du stattdessen
Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen schreibst.
Das hat genau die gleiche Semantik,
außer dass es nicht auf Truthiness checkt,
sondern nur, ob das vordere Undefined oder Null ist.
Also ist es wie der Null-Coalescing-Operator?
Das ist ein Null-Coalescing-Operator.
Das ist ein toller Operator.
Den mag ich sehr.
Schön.
Guter Freund von mir, dieser Operator.
Den gibt es in Swift auch?
Ja.
Ja, genau. Und den gibt es auch in JavaScript.
Die Leute schauen allgemein, ich finde es gut,
wenn Leute bei Programmiersprachendesign
über den Tellerrand hinaus schauen.
Das machen auch fast alle außer die Ziplus.
Die machen es am besten.
Die implementieren ja wirklich alle Features anderer Sprachen.
Ja, aber immer subtil,
anders und so ein bisschen seltsam.
Also warte mal, das, was ihr da einbaut,
zum Beispiel Structured Bindings,
ja, das gibt es auch bereits
in fünf anderen ML-basierten
Sprachen, aber offenbar
wusstet ihr das nicht, als ihr das implementiert habt.
Bei vielen C++ Features
denke ich mir, das haben sie sich doch neu ausgedacht.
Aber muss ich lassen, die nehmen halt wirklich
alles, alles. Es bleibt kein Feature in irgendeiner
Sprache, das nicht irgendwie seinen Weg in C++ findet.
Ja, ich weiß nicht,
fehlt mir trotzdem immer noch irgendwas.
Es fehlen die Dinge jetzt hier.
Das muss ich anders machen.
Ja.
Die heutige Folge ist übrigens gesponsert von
Oh, möchtest du das laut vorlesen?
Frumate.
Zitro.
Wo kommt die eigentlich her?
Hat mich Hendrik vorhin mit überrascht.
Aus dem Hause Frukate.
Keine Ahnung, wo das herkommt.
Privatbrauerei Kessel.
Obwohl, das ist in Marktsteffen.
Nie gehört.
Die Postleitzahl nach ist es auch nicht in der Nähe.
Ja, ich gehe manchmal hier...
Frukate?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich war im Getränkemarkt,
wo auch das ASCII bestellt
und da lade ich mir dann immer mal so einen Kasten
irgendwie hier so Gurkenlimo und Mater ein.
Du bist der eine Mensch, der Gurkenlimo
hat keiner trinkt.
Ich habe auch früher mal Bier gekauft,
aber es ist bei mir einfach nie alle gewohnt.
Und da gab es irgendwie diese seltsame aussehende Mater
und die darf ich einfach mal ausprobieren.
Das ist irgendwie so ein deutsches Ding,
dass es bei uns so viele Maten gibt.
Irgendwie, ja, habe ich das Gefühl.
Das sehe ich in anderen Ländern nicht wirklich.
Die Deutschen sind irgendwie Martegeil.
Vielleicht, weil sie es so schön deutsch ausspricht.
Marte.
Club Marte.
Jeder hat, glaube ich, anfangs gedacht,
beim ersten Mal, dass es Clubmate heißt.
Vielleicht, ja.
Ich hätte gerne so ein Clubmate.
Clubmate heißt Club Marte, du Spack.
Don't call it Clubmate.
Okay, haben wir noch was?
Club Marte.
Club Marte wird bald 100.
Hatten wir das Thema schon?
Echt?
Stimmt.
Die gibt es seit 1924.
Das haben wir auch mal erwähnt.
Bald.
Ja, also ein paar Jahre noch, aber
Hallo? Gibt es da noch akronomisierbar
2024? Ja, sicher.
Uns gibt es jetzt bald zwei Jahre, ne?
Erst zwei?
Drei?
Dann machen wir aber sehr wenig Folgen. Ach stimmt, so im Schnitt
so einen Monat oder eine anderthalb
Monate. Das kommt doch ganz gut hin, oder? Ja.
Ich würde mich wundern, wenn
wir in zwei Jahren auf 34 Folgen geschafft haben.
Das ist ja rapides Tempo.
Habe ich schon gearbeitet, als wir
angefangen haben? Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Wann ist die erste Folge Akronymistie raus?
Wir brauchen mal ein bisschen mehr Volltextsuche,
habe ich übrigens gelernt.
Da habe ich was gefunden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was für uns ist.
Descript, kennst du das?
Nee, ich weiß nicht,
aber ich hatte die ersten Folgen mal alle durch Wit.ai gejagt.
Sie machen generell so Intent-Parsing und Speech-Ecognition,
aber das ist ein Service von Facebook.
Aber das habe ich nur gemacht,
weil es einfach ein Klick anhaken bei Authonic war.
Aber das hat nie gut funktioniert,
weil es halt deutscher Content ist.
Ach so.
Also es gibt hier irgendwie,
jetzt läuft hier bereits voll das Werbevideo für Descript.
Da hatte irgendwie der Khalil,
Kollege von mir,
der von,
da hatte irgendwie Khalil,
Kollege von mir, irgendwie auch mal,
der auch podcastet, mal rumgefragt,
gibt es irgendwie schon so ein Ding, mit dem man
Podcasts direkt mit
Mitschnitten aufzeichnen kann und das ist
irgendwie dieses Ding.
Du edit audio with text, also
das ist,
das sieht eigentlich ganz fett aus, das sieht so aus,
als ob du wirklich auf dem, du siehst hier die
Höhlenkurve von dem Audio und es steht oben drüber,
was da stand.
was da gesagt wurde und dann kannst du quasi
gezielt nach Wörtern beim Editieren suchen
und die rausediten. Ich wollte mal ein Python-Skript
schreiben, das quasi so ein, das mit
einem Video macht, dass du halt wirklich einfach Text
hingibst und einen Video-Link
der zieht mal das Video runter,
dann zerstückelt er das, nutzt irgendwelche, da gibt es
passende Python-Libraries, direkt hier
speech-er-technischen machen, zerstückelt das Video
in einzelne Wortfragmente
und baut die so zusammen, dass dein Wunschtext hinten
rauskommt wieder zu einem Video. Das gibt es doch garantiert schon.
Wer macht denn diese ganzen komischen Musik-Videos, wo
der amerikanische Präsident auf euch Lieder singt,
die er nicht gesungen hat.
Es gibt sowas, wo sie Wortfetzen von Obama
verwenden und dann mit dem Autotune
den wirklich singen lassen.
Aber man muss
es natürlich auch mal selbst gebastelt haben.
Nee, mit Flo kam ich auf die Idee.
Hey Flo, falls du das hier zufällig hören solltest.
Viele Grüße nach Afrika.
Der ist in Afrika?
Abgefahren. Ja, zumindest irgendwie gibt es dieses
Dings hier und das, ich meine,
Sprache erkennen auf Audio, das ist ja wirklich
mittlerweile ein gelöstes Problem,
dir einfach ein bisschen was reinziehst und dann hast du so eine Lipp,
die das für dich macht.
Und dann siehst du halt, wer was wann gesagt hat.
Das ist schon ganz cool.
Mich würde mal der Redeanteil, wenn man das mal
visualisieren würde,
von unserem Podcast interessieren.
Das kannst du wahrscheinlich sogar...
Ob wir auf 50-50 kommen? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Bei den Folgen, seitdem wir mit der neuen
Autotechnik hier sitzen und Eis in den Mikros haben, könnte man
das über die Tracks sicherlich relativ
low-tech rauskriegen, oder?
Naja,
vielleicht.
Das schmeiße ich einfach nachträglich nochmal in sowas hier rein.
Hm, das würde ich mir
auf jeden Fall nochmal anschauen. Gut, das ist natürlich
ordentlich, sondern nicht anschaulich für die Leute, die gerade zuhören.
Anschaulich für Podcast-Zuhörer
ist generell so ein Ding.
Aber ansonsten sind wir schon ein recht anschaulicher Podcast.
Wir sind sehr anhörlich.
Bevor wir zum Ende wahrscheinlich langsam kommen,
würde ich gerne noch eine Podcast-Empfehlung
loswerden. Oh ja, Podcast-Empfehlung.
Ich hatte jetzt vor
kurzem angefangen, mal wieder
The Office zu bingen.
eine sehr, sehr tolle Fernsehserie
für die Leute, die sie vielleicht noch nicht kennen sollten.
Und The Office hat gerade irgendwie
so eine Renaissance erlebt, habe ich das Gefühl, im Internet.
Aber wahrscheinlich, weil Netflix die irgendwie nochmal gepusht hat.
Wahrscheinlich bringt Netflix irgendwie ein Sequel oder ein Prequel raus.
Dann machen sie doch gerade von allem möglich.
Aber Netflix hat die, glaube ich, auch schon wieder aus dem Sotinett genommen,
wenn ich mich nicht alles täusche. Auf jeden Fall,
tolle Serie und irgendwie, das fand ich sehr witzig,
ich habe die Serie angefangen zu schauen.
The Office,
dieses Vorbild für Stromberg?
Quasi, ja.
Genau. Also Stromberg fand ich ganz nett
früher mal, aber es hat mich nie wirklich,
fand ich nie so lustig, vielleicht war ich noch nicht bereit für Cringe-Comedy.
Es hat einfach so eine...
Cringe-Comedy ist auch weird, finde ich. Cringe-Comedy ist generell
ein tolles Format, finde ich. Cringe-Comedy?
Cringe-Comedy. Oder Fringe-Comedy? Cringe.
Witzig durch Cringiness.
Also ich liebe es.
Also The Office ist ein passendes Beispiel für, oder auch so Sachen
wie Nathan for You ist auch eine fantastische Serie.
Stromberg kann ich nicht so viel anfangen, aber
The Office ist eine tolle Serie, habe ich es schon fünfmal gesagt.
Worauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus? Genau.
Gibt es jetzt einen Podcast?
Da gibt es einen Podcast jetzt, der heißt Office Ladies
und der ist mit
zwei von den Hauptdarstellerinnen, Pam
und Angela, Jenna Fischer und
Angela, ich habe den Nachnamen vergessen,
die jetzt darüber reden,
haufenweise witzige Fakten zur Serie
heraushalten, Behind-the-Seed-Kram, die schauen
quasi nochmal die Serie und reden
im Anschluss über jede Folge einfach nochmal so eine Stunde,
was sie nochmal hatten.
Der hat, glaube ich, die letzte Woche erst angefangen, der Podcast.
Super witzig.
Das scheint irgendwie so ein neues Genre zu sein. Es gibt ja auch
der
zu jeder Minute von Matrix
irgendwie eine Folge macht. Das fand ich ein bisschen
anstrengend. Hast du den mal gehört?
Ich hab mal reingehört. Die ersten fünf Minuten
habe ich mir angehört. Also die ersten fünf Folgen oder so.
Aber allgemein so, es gab einen ziemlich guten Podcast
zu Tschernobyl.
Zu der Serie.
Wo sie mit dem
Autor und Regisseur, das ist ja eine Person,
ein Interviewformat
hatten. Da gab es exakt fünf Folgen
von dem Podcast zu jeder Folge von der
Serie.
auf jeden Fall sehr
hörenswert, also ich habe mir die Serie
einfach nochmal angeguckt und dann
nach jeder Folge diese Podcast-Folgen angehört
war sehr gut
es gibt irgendwie den Rick and Morty Podcast
die folgen uns auf Twitter
das ist ein deutscher Rick and Morty Podcast
ein paar Jahre her gab es noch den Firefly Cast
die Leute, die Firefly-Folgen haben
das sind dieselben Leute, die auch diesen Matrix-Podcast haben
es ist sicher der
Alexander So und So
vom Hoaxilla
das weiß ich nicht mehr
Aber es wäre witzig, wenn das so ist. Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ich höre zumindest manchmal noch
Hoaxfiller, der erzählt, dass der auch noch andere Podcasts
macht. So, jetzt haben
wir sehr viele Sachen, die wir in Shownotes reinschmeißen
müssen, damit wir auch genügend
eigentlich ist es nur so eine Name-Drop-Folge.
Wir haben uns nicht
gut vorbereitet, aber wir haben hier, was wir mal erwähnt haben,
was die Leute sich einfach selber so anhören können.
Sorry, manchmal sind einfach solche Tage.
Dafür, dass wir jetzt zwei Monate lang
keine Folge gemacht haben, machen wir jetzt hier so eine.
Das tut mir fast ein bisschen leid.
Aber nächstes Mal machen wir wieder ein Interview-Format.
Hoffen wir, dass es die nächste Folge wird.
Da muss die Person dann aber auch zu dem Zeitpunkt
vielleicht ist auch erst das übernächste Mal, mal schauen.
Ja, irgendwann demnächst kriegen wir mal eine Folge hin,
dass wir wirklich über gar nichts reden.
So wie es
Fernsehserien gibt, die eine Folge lang
nur ein Bild von einem Toastbrot zeigen.
Ne, von einem Marmeladenglas.
Was?
Das war so ein Witz aus Rock'n's modernes Leben.
Wir haben dann eine Folge lang nur ein Marmeladenglas
gezeigt und die Leute fanden es trotzdem geil.
Keine Reference.
Wir spielen dann eine Stunde lang im Podcast
nur das Geräusch eines dröhnen Kühlschranks ab.
Ich höre es mir anhören.
Ja?
Vielleicht so beim Einschlafen oder so.
Sehr gut.
Weil ja sonst von solchen
Kühlschrankgeräuschen wachgehalten wird.
Also generell einfach mal so ein Podcast,
der in jeder Folge einfach nur ein
so ein, nicht so ein Backgroundgeräusch,
aber ein Geräusch halt einfach nur auf eine Stunde
so ein Deep Dive in das Geräusch quasi macht.
ohne Erklärung, einfach nur das Geräusch eine Stunde lang.
Ob das jetzt eine schnurrende Katze
ist oder eine Waschmaschine.
Es gibt diesen geilen
Bassisten auf YouTube,
der macht so Bass, eigentlich hat er
jahrelang bloß Videos
gemacht, wie er Bass spielt oder was nachspielt oder was zeigt.
Und jetzt hat er einfach sein Channel-Format
so ein bisschen geändert, wo er einfach tatsächlich
redet und irgendwie entweder
Challenges für andere Basser raushaut.
Das ist cool, da gibt es irgendwie eine Seite, wo du kannst
irgendwie von Künstlern dir Dienste einkaufen.
Da hat er reingeschrieben,
ich möchte das geilste Solo auf was haben
und biete so und so viel Geld.
Oder die Leute kamen dann an, ja, ich mach das für 20,
ich mach das für 60, ich mach das für 200 Dollar.
Und dann hat er sich die alle reingeholt und einfach abgespielt
der Reihe nach.
Er hat irgendwie ein Background eingespielt
oder er hat irgendwas total Unmögliches gespielt,
hat nicht gezeigt, wie er es gespielt hat, aber dass es
unmöglich zu spielen ist. Und hat dann Leuten
gesagt, hier, spiel das mal und hat dann einfach die Reaktion gesammelt.
Das ist ja auch witzig.
Unabhängig davon, weil wir ja gerade bei dem Kühlschrank waren,
der hat dann irgendwie in seinem Video zum Schluss immer eine Sektion,
wo das so,
Psychologie-Teil oder so ein
Therapie-Teil
quasi, wo sich deine Probleme
anhört.
Er hört einfach auf zu reden und guckt so
in die Kamera
und macht so...
Das ist ja gut.
Oh ja.
Oh, das ist hart.
Das geht echt fünf Minuten lang.
dieses Segment.
Herrlich.
Das können wir auch machen.
Das ist ja wunderschön.
Ja, ich glaube, damit haben wir jetzt irgendwie auch
einen Punkt erreicht.
Also, lieber akronomisierbarer Zuhörer,
das war
Folge...
33.
Ja, sowas. Grob im Dreh.
Wir lassen die Einerstelle einfach wegfallen
und reden nur in der Zehnerstelle.
Folge 3X ist das jetzt.
Wann machen wir dann den Umbruch zur 4X?
Ah, shit.
Wenn es uns passt.
Das ist Folge 4X gewesen.
Wir verabschieden uns hiermit
bei euch. Vielen Dank, dass ihr
wieder eine Folge akronomisierbar gehört habt.
Und für diejenigen von euch da draußen,
die heute einen
nicht so angenehmen oder anstrengenden Tag
hatten.
Die einfach mal
jemanden brauchen, dem sie ihren Kummer
erzählen müssen. Jetzt hören wir euch
noch drei Minuten zu.
Ihr könnt ja einfach mal jetzt kurz Pause drücken und in der
Zeit hören wir euch zu für so lange, wie ihr braucht.
Ich hätte das jetzt gemacht.
Also erzählt uns euren Kummer
ab jetzt.
Nicht lachen,
du hast angefangen.
Sorry.
Ich glaube, wir können es leider nicht.
Wir haben kein Psychologiestudium.
Achso, das brauchen wir dafür.
Okay, bevor es jetzt noch...
Wie hieß denn dieser Typ aus dem
Mincorrected Bratzo?
Oder?
Ja, der einfach in die Kamera guckt, der den
gebenden Blick hat.
Was haben wir, das Gebende zu hören?
Können wir das Cover-Art
hier am Ende einfach mal rein? Ja, klar, das kriege ich hin.
Brat so an.
Das ist irgendwie trademark in Twitter, wenn wir seinen gebenden Blick.
Das gibt es auf
Mint Correct hat das auf Twitter ständig.
Das tut ja wie auf T-Shirts.
Also wenn ihr mal wirklich hier gerade, wenn es euch nicht gut geht,
schaut jetzt mal euren Podcast-Player an,
der hoffentlich Coverart für einzelne Sektionen
unterstützt, dann werdet ihr jetzt
sicherlich gut angeschaut
und von Braco geheilt
durch seinen Gebenblick.
Wenn ihr nicht wisst, wer Braco ist, ich packe glaube ich mal noch
ein Link in die Schau. Ich gebe euch noch 10 Sekunden,
um Braco in die Augen zu gucken
und von ihm geheilt zu werden.
Und danach wünschen wir viel Spaß
bei nachfolgenden Podcast-Produktionen
anderer Studios.
Und der nächste Podcast in eurem
Podcatcher beginnt in 10.
9. 8.
Warum so lang? Sieben?
Sechs. Fünf.
Damit die Leute sich Pratzo angucken.
Vier. Drei.
Zwo. Eins.
Tschüss.
Oh Mann.
Pratzo.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich war.